Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 31, Unix Commands. Take it away, Jason. Hey, so I had an absolutely terrifying moment over the Christmas holidays. I moved a bunch of pictures from my camera to a USB drive that was connected to the router. And I didn't realize until now, I didn't quite think about it, but, you know, like the USB
Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 31, Unix Commands. Take it away, Jason. Hey, so I had an absolutely terrifying moment over the Christmas holidays. I moved a bunch of pictures from my camera to a USB drive that was connected to the router. And I didn't realize until now, I didn't quite think about it, but, you know, like the USB|||由 Host Tornado 提供托管服务。他们提供网站托管套餐、独立服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 31 期，Unix 命令。请开始，Jason。嘿，我在圣诞假期期间经历了一个绝对让人后怕的时刻。我把相机里的一堆照片移到了连接在路由器上的 USB 驱动器上。直到现在我才意识到，我当时没有多想，但是，你知道，就像那个 USB
drive had a journaling file system, I think it was NTFS. And so, you know like the the usb drive had a journaling file system i think it was ntfs and so you know the way journaling file system works is the driver kind of likes it says i forget the term for it but it like writes things to kind of like some cache and then at some point decides to sort of flush the cache and write it right actually write it to disk you know and you know being totally incompetent like any you know person who works on a modem like if you ever have like a router like a wireless router it's always terrible like i bought tons of them they always they're always terrible so i trusted my file system these people which is a huge mistake and uh the router like just we
drive had a journaling file system, I think it was NTFS. And so, you know like the the usb drive had a journaling file system i think it was ntfs and so you know the way journaling file system works is the driver kind of likes it says i forget the term for it but it like writes things to kind of like some cache and then at some point decides to sort of flush the cache and write it right actually write it to disk you know and you know being totally incompetent like any you know person who works on a modem like if you ever have like a router like a wireless router it's always terrible like i bought tons of them they always they're always terrible so i trusted my file system these people which is a huge mistake and uh the router like just we|||驱动器有一个日志文件系统，我想那是 NTFS。所以，你知道，就像那个 USB 驱动器有一个日志文件系统，我想那是 NTFS，所以你知道日志文件系统的工作方式是驱动程序有点像它说的那样——我忘了这个术语叫什么了——但它像把东西写入某种缓存，然后在某个时间点决定把缓存清空并写入，实际上是写入磁盘，你知道的，而且你知道，就像任何在调制解调器上工作的人一样完全不称职，如果你曾经用过路由器，比如无线路由器，它总是糟糕透顶——我买过无数个，它们总是、它们总是很糟糕——所以我信任了这些人的文件系统，这是一个巨大的错误，然后路由器就像我们……
lost power a couple days later. I mean, this is literally days later. And the photos were just gone. And it was all the photos I'd taken of the baby, like, for the first six months, you know? So wait, why did you hook it into the router in the first place? Presumably you were going to copy it off?
lost power a couple days later. I mean, this is literally days later. And the photos were just gone. And it was all the photos I'd taken of the baby, like, for the first six months, you know? So wait, why did you hook it into the router in the first place? Presumably you were going to copy it off?|||几天后断电了。我是说，真的只是几天后。照片就这样没了。那全是我给宝宝拍的照片，比如头六个月的照片，你知道吗？等等，那你当初为什么要把它插到路由器上？大概你是打算把它复制下来吧？
No, well, you know, I just thought that, like, I actually have a NAS, but the thing is is the NAS is a little slow to access, especially if, like, my wife, she likes to look at a bunch of pictures at the same time. And so I figured if it was on the modem, it would be one less hop. When really, like, it didn't really matter because the NAS is plugged straight into the modem.
No, well, you know, I just thought that, like, I actually have a NAS, but the thing is is the NAS is a little slow to access, especially if, like, my wife, she likes to look at a bunch of pictures at the same time. And so I figured if it was on the modem, it would be one less hop. When really, like, it didn't really matter because the NAS is plugged straight into the modem.|||不，嗯，你知道，我只是觉得，其实我有 NAS，但问题是 NAS 访问起来有点慢，尤其是如果像我妻子那样，她喜欢同时看一堆照片。所以我想如果它在调制解调器上，就会少一跳。但实际上，这根本无所谓，因为 NAS 直接插在调制解调器上。
It was kind of silly. But, you know, at the time, you don't expect there to be this issue, right? So at any rate, so i was really freaking out and then you know her computer i tried to like recover um you know the files off her computer but uh so just a quick heads up for people out there in the audience who who didn't know this i actually didn't know this for a really long time. I only learned it rather recently. When you erase something, there's just a journal on the file system that says, hey, this file doesn't exist anymore. This index doesn't exist anymore.
It was kind of silly. But, you know, at the time, you don't expect there to be this issue, right? So at any rate, so i was really freaking out and then you know her computer i tried to like recover um you know the files off her computer but uh so just a quick heads up for people out there in the audience who who didn't know this i actually didn't know this for a really long time. I only learned it rather recently. When you erase something, there's just a journal on the file system that says, hey, this file doesn't exist anymore. This index doesn't exist anymore.|||这有点蠢。但是，你知道，当时你不会预料到会有这种问题，对吧？所以不管怎样，我当时真的快急疯了，然后你知道她的电脑，我试着恢复，嗯，你知道她电脑里的文件，但是，嗯，给听众朋友们提个醒，可能有人不知道这一点——其实我也不知道，持续了很长一段时间。我直到最近才知道。当你擦除某个东西时，文件系统上只有一个日志，上面写着，嘿，这个文件不存在了。这个索引不存在了。
But on the physical disk, there's still electrons and they still have, for the most part, the same kind of charge that they did, you know, in the file existence. No, electrons always have the same charge. What was that? The electrons always have the same charge. Well, so... No, I'm just giving you a hard time.
But on the physical disk, there's still electrons and they still have, for the most part, the same kind of charge that they did, you know, in the file existence. No, electrons always have the same charge. What was that? The electrons always have the same charge. Well, so... No, I'm just giving you a hard time.|||但在物理磁盘上，仍然有电子，而且在大多数情况下，它们仍然拥有和文件存在时完全相同的电荷。不对，电子的电荷总是相同的。刚才说什么？电子的电荷总是相同的。好吧，所以……不，我只是在跟你开玩笑。
No, yeah, so, well, you know what I mean. You mean the flash, the bits of flash are still flashed the same way, but it's just the header that says there's a file here has been erased or been deleted. But then what happened was my wife's computer, which is what we put the pictures on before moving them to the USB drive, it defragged. It did a defrag, like a full defrag, which it does like every day. And so now like all of that electricity has been moved to a different location,
No, yeah, so, well, you know what I mean. You mean the flash, the bits of flash are still flashed the same way, but it's just the header that says there's a file here has been erased or been deleted. But then what happened was my wife's computer, which is what we put the pictures on before moving them to the USB drive, it defragged. It did a defrag, like a full defrag, which it does like every day. And so now like all of that electricity has been moved to a different location,|||不，对，所以，好吧，你知道我的意思。你是说闪存，闪存位仍然以相同的方式闪烁，但只是说这里有个文件的标头被擦除或删除了。但接下来发生的事情是，我妻子的电脑——也就是我们在把照片移到 USB 驱动器之前存放照片的地方——它进行了碎片整理。它做了碎片整理，就像完全碎片整理一样，它每天都这样做。所以现在所有的电荷都被移动到了不同的位置，
and I couldn't recover anything. But then we were actually able to recover the files off of the camera's SD card because we don't do any defrag or anything on that. So it was pretty scary, but at least I got all the files. I set up a cloud account since then everything so i have everything backed up in the cloud and i have okay good so but wait so you should have been able to just run like a file recovery program on the usb drive and gotten your pictures back as well no so i tried but uh for whatever reason it didn't work yeah the usb drive just like i don't quite
and I couldn't recover anything. But then we were actually able to recover the files off of the camera's SD card because we don't do any defrag or anything on that. So it was pretty scary, but at least I got all the files. I set up a cloud account since then everything so i have everything backed up in the cloud and i have okay good so but wait so you should have been able to just run like a file recovery program on the usb drive and gotten your pictures back as well no so i tried but uh for whatever reason it didn't work yeah the usb drive just like i don't quite|||我什么也恢复不了了。但后来我们实际上能够从相机的 SD 卡中恢复文件，因为我们没有对它进行任何碎片整理。所以这挺吓人的，但至少我找回了所有的文件。从那以后我设置了一个云账户，所以一切都在云端备份了，我——好吧，很好，但是等等，那你本应该可以在 USB 驱动器上运行类似文件恢复程序的软件，然后把照片也找回来啊？不，我试过了，但是，不知什么原因，它没用，是的，那个 USB 驱动器就像是——我不太清楚那里发生了什么，但是的，我试过了，那是我尝试的第一件事，它们就是无法恢复，是的。
know what happened there but yeah i tried that that was the first thing i tried they wouldn't recover yeah okay i i would throw away your router or just never never plug never plug don't plug things you don't want to lose into it yeah you know why is it that no one can make a good router it just seems like it's really hard no no it's really hard i mean it's it's like a high performance device that's supposed to be really cheap and do like a lot of things right like it needs to have like a wireless router at least it needs to do both be like a good lan router you know like switch router thing, whatever. I'm terrible with networking stuff, but the physical, you know, port switching, but then also needs to do that
know what happened there but yeah i tried that that was the first thing i tried they wouldn't recover yeah okay i i would throw away your router or just never never plug never plug don't plug things you don't want to lose into it yeah you know why is it that no one can make a good router it just seems like it's really hard no no it's really hard i mean it's it's like a high performance device that's supposed to be really cheap and do like a lot of things right like it needs to have like a wireless router at least it needs to do both be like a good lan router you know like switch router thing, whatever. I'm terrible with networking stuff, but the physical, you know, port switching, but then also needs to do that|||好吧，我——我会把你的路由器扔掉，或者永远、永远不要插、永远不要插——不要把不想丢失的东西插进去。是的，你知道为什么没人能做出一个好路由器吗？这看起来真的很难。不，不，这真的很难。我的意思是，它就像是一个高性能设备，却被要求非常便宜，并且要做很多事情，对吧？比如它至少需要有一个无线路由器，它需要兼顾两方面，既要成为一个好的局域网路由器，你知道的，比如交换机路由器之类的，随便什么。我对网络方面的东西一窍不通，但物理上的，你知道的，端口交换，然后还需要为……
for all the wifi connections and, you know, have good RF design to have good wifi reception and transmission. I mean, that's like a lot of different things to go on. And on top of the fact that like, I think a lot of the stuff we were using like the wireless you know 802 11 b and g and even in are what over 10 years old and 10 years ago we didn't like in my house there's probably 20 or more devices on the wi-fi at a given time yeah yeah definitely when you know when they were designed people probably had one or maybe two computers that had Wi-Fi modems on them or whatever. Yeah, they have that new 5G 802 AC or something like that. I don't know anything about networking either.
for all the wifi connections and, you know, have good RF design to have good wifi reception and transmission. I mean, that's like a lot of different things to go on. And on top of the fact that like, I think a lot of the stuff we were using like the wireless you know 802 11 b and g and even in are what over 10 years old and 10 years ago we didn't like in my house there's probably 20 or more devices on the wi-fi at a given time yeah yeah definitely when you know when they were designed people probably had one or maybe two computers that had Wi-Fi modems on them or whatever. Yeah, they have that new 5G 802 AC or something like that. I don't know anything about networking either.|||所有的 wifi 连接提供服务，并且，你知道的，要有良好的射频设计以获得良好的 wifi 接收和传输。我的意思是，这有太多不同的事情要处理了。除此之外，我认为我们使用的许多东西，比如无线网络，你知道的，802.11 b、g 甚至 n，都已经有 10 多年的历史了，而在 10 年前，我们家里在任何给定时间可能都没有像现在这样有 20 个或更多的设备连接在 wifi 上。是的，是的，绝对的，你知道当它们被设计的时候，人们可能只有一台或两台带有 wifi 调制解调器或其他东西的电脑。是的，他们有那个新的 5G 802.11ac 或类似的东西。我对网络也一无所知。
But supposedly they have a new one that just came out, which is way better. But of course, then it's like your device, the endpoint also has to support it, right? Like whatever phone you have or whatever. Right, yeah, your also has to support it, right? Like whatever phone you have or whatever. Right, yeah, your phone has to have it. Same thing like 5 gigahertz even. So 2.4 gigahertz is really crowded with a lot of devices. From my house, I can see 10 or 15 different Wi-Fi routers from all the neighbors. So the space is really congested which causes speed problems
But supposedly they have a new one that just came out, which is way better. But of course, then it's like your device, the endpoint also has to support it, right? Like whatever phone you have or whatever. Right, yeah, your also has to support it, right? Like whatever phone you have or whatever. Right, yeah, your phone has to have it. Same thing like 5 gigahertz even. So 2.4 gigahertz is really crowded with a lot of devices. From my house, I can see 10 or 15 different Wi-Fi routers from all the neighbors. So the space is really congested which causes speed problems|||但据说他们刚推出了一款新的，要好得多。但当然，这就意味着你的设备，即终端也必须支持它，对吧？比如你有什么手机之类的。对，是的，你的手机也必须支持它，对吧？比如你有什么手机之类的。对，是的，你的手机必须具备这个功能。同样的，甚至连 5 吉赫兹也是如此。因此，2.4 吉赫兹挤满了大量设备。从我家望出去，我能看到邻居们的 10 到 15 个不同的 Wi-Fi 路由器。所以这个空间真的非常拥挤，从而导致了速度问题，
and so five gigahertz is less crowded and i believe there's more channels so it's it's a little bit better but five gigahertz doesn't have as good of a range as 2.4 gigahertz and still tons of stuff doesn't support five gigahertz so you can buy new products today that still don't have five gigahertz support in them oh gotcha yeah i mean this might be the thing we're like we're just a couple of generations away from them getting this right you know it's like this can't be that hard it's like the mouse you know i feel like you know they got the mouse right and then there hasn't been that many changes to it yeah well i mean i think there was supposed to be when they went all the tv stations went digital from analog that space was supposed to get freed up for this kind of thing to be able to be done um in in that the old where tv
and so five gigahertz is less crowded and i believe there's more channels so it's it's a little bit better but five gigahertz doesn't have as good of a range as 2.4 gigahertz and still tons of stuff doesn't support five gigahertz so you can buy new products today that still don't have five gigahertz support in them oh gotcha yeah i mean this might be the thing we're like we're just a couple of generations away from them getting this right you know it's like this can't be that hard it's like the mouse you know i feel like you know they got the mouse right and then there hasn't been that many changes to it yeah well i mean i think there was supposed to be when they went all the tv stations went digital from analog that space was supposed to get freed up for this kind of thing to be able to be done um in in that the old where tv|||所以 5 吉赫兹的拥挤程度较低，而且我相信有更多信道，所以它会好一些，但 5 吉赫兹的范围没有 2.4 吉赫兹那么好，而且仍然有大量的东西不支持 5 吉赫兹，所以你今天买的新产品可能仍然没有 5 吉赫兹支持。哦，明白了。是的，我的意思是，这可能是那种我们离他们把这事做好只差几代产品的情况，你知道的，这不应该这么难，就像鼠标一样，我感觉，你知道的，他们把鼠标做对了，然后就没有发生过太多改变。嗯，我的意思是，我想本该是这样的：当所有电视台从模拟信号转为数字信号时，那片频段本该腾出来用于这类事情，嗯，在那个旧的电视……
stations used to live in the rf spectrum but uh i think through various whatever the auctions and legislation got changed and so it didn't end up being a very uh good idea for companies to do that so it went to the same people that already do like the cell phone spectrum basically so it didn't end up being a very good idea for companies to do that. So it went to the same people that already do like the cell phone spectrum, basically. So it didn't really make a big change. Gotcha. All right. All right, on to the news. News.
stations used to live in the rf spectrum but uh i think through various whatever the auctions and legislation got changed and so it didn't end up being a very uh good idea for companies to do that so it went to the same people that already do like the cell phone spectrum basically so it didn't end up being a very good idea for companies to do that. So it went to the same people that already do like the cell phone spectrum, basically. So it didn't really make a big change. Gotcha. All right. All right, on to the news. News.|||台曾经占据的射频频谱中，但是，我想通过各种拍卖和立法变更，结果对公司来说这并不是一个非常好的主意，所以它基本上还是归了那些原本就做手机频段的人。所以结果对公司来说并不是一个非常好的主意。所以它基本上还是归了那些原本就做手机频段的人。所以它并没有带来太大的改变。明白了。好的。好的，进入新闻环节。新闻。
So the first one here, it's maybe more of a that's interesting slash discussion. But somebody built a 32 node raspberry pi supercomputer cluster and i think somebody has done this before i'm sure we've even maybe had one of these in a previous programming throwdown um where somebody did this yeah i remember this it got like a lot of this one you know got press or whatever somebody was trying to run uh they were actually doing distributed sensor nodes and this one had a interesting caveat where they did a good job of actually saying like you know this is kind of impractical for most things like a supercomputer is something different or way better or even just running on you know a couple
So the first one here, it's maybe more of a that's interesting slash discussion. But somebody built a 32 node raspberry pi supercomputer cluster and i think somebody has done this before i'm sure we've even maybe had one of these in a previous programming throwdown um where somebody did this yeah i remember this it got like a lot of this one you know got press or whatever somebody was trying to run uh they were actually doing distributed sensor nodes and this one had a interesting caveat where they did a good job of actually saying like you know this is kind of impractical for most things like a supercomputer is something different or way better or even just running on you know a couple|||所以这里的第一个，可能更多是一个“真有趣/值得讨论”的话题。但有人用树莓派搭建了一个 32 节点的超级计算机集群，而且我想以前有人这么做过，我确信我们甚至可能在之前的某期 Programming Throwdown 中讨论过有人这么做。是的，我记得这个，它得到了很多……这个你知道的，受到了媒体关注还是怎么的，有人尝试运行……他们实际上在做分布式传感器节点，而这个项目有一个有趣的警告，他们做得很好，明确表示“你知道的，这对大多数事情来说有点不切实际，超级计算机是完全不同的东西，要好得多，甚至仅仅在……
high performance computers might do a better job than putting all these raspberry pies but um Pi's, but the person specifically was using some extra sensor and radio communications things and they were using the general purpose I.O. ports on the Raspberry Pi to interface to those things. So by having this cluster of them that way, he was able to simulate a sensor node better, or at least that's the gist I got from the article. So I thought it was an interesting subject and kind of one of those things where i guess you said you spent about two thousand dollars building it um which is far cheaper than you know most things so if it's the right tool for the right job you know i've seen people kind of spend more than like even like i
high performance computers might do a better job than putting all these raspberry pies but um Pi's, but the person specifically was using some extra sensor and radio communications things and they were using the general purpose I.O. ports on the Raspberry Pi to interface to those things. So by having this cluster of them that way, he was able to simulate a sensor node better, or at least that's the gist I got from the article. So I thought it was an interesting subject and kind of one of those things where i guess you said you spent about two thousand dollars building it um which is far cheaper than you know most things so if it's the right tool for the right job you know i've seen people kind of spend more than like even like i|||几台高性能计算机上运行，可能也比把所有这些树莓派连起来效果更好”，但嗯，树莓派（Pi's），这个人特别使用了一些额外的传感器和无线电通信设备，他们使用树莓派上的通用输入输出（I.O.）端口来与这些设备进行接口。因此，通过以这种方式将它们集群化，他能够更好地模拟传感器节点，至少这是我从文章中了解到的要旨。所以我认为这是一个有趣的主题，而且属于那种——我想你说你花了大约两千美元来建造它——这比你知道的大多数东西要便宜得多，所以如果它是适合这项工作的正确工具，你知道，我见过有人花的钱甚至比……
was like oh i get a raspberry pi to play around with but then you forget like you need the raspberry pi and an sd card and a you know wi-fi usb thing if you're going to use one um you know you like add up all the things it's like oh man this is actually kind of like gonna be like a hundred dollars and what am i really gonna do with it hmm yeah that's the issue i ran into i was on the order like q for one but when my turn came to buy one i just realized that yeah i didn't have any good ideas yeah so like if you knew like oh i'm gonna use it to do this like it would you know it makes sense anyways right tool for the right job but yeah raspberry pi supercomputer i still these raspberry pies i thought they would just like kind of be a flash in the pan and people would kind of like
was like oh i get a raspberry pi to play around with but then you forget like you need the raspberry pi and an sd card and a you know wi-fi usb thing if you're going to use one um you know you like add up all the things it's like oh man this is actually kind of like gonna be like a hundred dollars and what am i really gonna do with it hmm yeah that's the issue i ran into i was on the order like q for one but when my turn came to buy one i just realized that yeah i didn't have any good ideas yeah so like if you knew like oh i'm gonna use it to do this like it would you know it makes sense anyways right tool for the right job but yeah raspberry pi supercomputer i still these raspberry pies i thought they would just like kind of be a flash in the pan and people would kind of like|||我当时想，哦，我买个树莓派来玩玩，但随后你忘了，比如你需要树莓派、一张 SD 卡、一个 Wi-Fi USB 设备（如果你要用的话），你知道的，当你把所有东西加起来时，就会觉得，天哪，这实际上差不多要一百美元了，而我到底能用它做什么呢？嗯，是的，这就是我遇到的问题。我当时在排队等候购买，但当轮到我买的时候，我突然意识到，是的，我根本没什么好主意。是的，所以如果你知道，哦，我要用它来做这个，那就（说得通了）……总之，适合的工具干适合的活，但是，树莓派超级计算机……我依然觉得这些树莓派，我本以为它们只会昙花一现，人们会……
move on but like they're still in the news and people are still talking about them so yay for raspberry pi yeah that's pretty cool did you see the like intel came out with some really cheap uh like single board computer thing right so i don't know really cheap is true but i saw they came out with yeah like a pentium processor that's like arduino compatible yeah that's right people kind of passed over it because it's kind of not the point um like it didn't make a lot of sense for people to do that but the space is heating up like more and more people are making arduino compatible boards and the arduino itself uses a basic microprocessor which is only 8-bit computer and not that fast
move on but like they're still in the news and people are still talking about them so yay for raspberry pi yeah that's pretty cool did you see the like intel came out with some really cheap uh like single board computer thing right so i don't know really cheap is true but i saw they came out with yeah like a pentium processor that's like arduino compatible yeah that's right people kind of passed over it because it's kind of not the point um like it didn't make a lot of things for people to do that but the space is heating up like more and more people are making arduino compatible boards and the arduino itself uses a basic microprocessor which is only 8-bit computer and not that fast|||继续前进，但它们依然常常出现在新闻中，人们也仍在谈论它们，所以为树莓派欢呼吧！是的，这挺酷的。你看到英特尔推出了一些非常便宜的单板计算机产品了吗？所以我不知道“非常便宜”是否属实，但我看到他们推出了，是的，就像是一个兼容 Arduino 的奔腾处理器。是的，没，人们有点忽视了它，因为这有点偏离重点，嗯，就像这对人们来说并没有太多可做的事情一样，但这个领域正在升温，越来越多的人在制作兼容 Arduino 的板子，而 Arduino 本身使用的是一个基础微处理器，它只是一个 8 位计算机，速度并不是那么快。
but then now there's ones with like 32-bit computers running you know significantly faster where you can do you know a lot more processing on them versus just like i'm gonna blink some leds yeah right no the arduino can do a lot more than that but yeah yeah but no definitely nothing like a raspberry pi or like this intel chip where you could do some serious like image processing or signal processing. Yep. So if you were going to do image processing and you created a startup to do that, you might be doomed. Yeah, that's right.
but then now there's ones with like 32-bit computers running you know significantly faster where you can do you know a lot more processing on them versus just like i'm gonna blink some leds yeah right no the arduino can do a lot more than that but yeah yeah but no definitely nothing like a raspberry pi or like this intel chip where you could do some serious like image processing or signal processing. Yep. So if you were going to do image processing and you created a startup to do that, you might be doomed. Yeah, that's right.|||但现在有些板子配备了 32 位计算机，运行速度明显更快，你可以在上面做更多的处理，而不仅仅是“我要让几个 LED 灯闪烁”。是的，没错，不，Arduino 能做的远不止这些，但是，是的，当然，它绝对比不上树莓派或这款英特尔芯片，你可以用它们做一些严肃的图像处理或信号处理。是的。所以，如果你要进行图像处理并为此创立了一家初创公司，那你可能就注定要失败了。是的，没错。
So my article is pretty cool. The title is Why the World's Best Photo Startup is Going Out of Business. Went Out of Business. Yeah. It's called the government. So I think that this article is, like, phenomenally interesting. It's on this app-based company called Everpix. And the idea here is they would take your photos, you know,
So my article is pretty cool. The title is Why the World's Best Photo Startup is Going Out of Business. Went Out of Business. Yeah. It's called the government. So I think that this article is, like, phenomenally interesting. It's on this app-based company called Everpix. And the idea here is they would take your photos, you know,|||所以我的这篇文章非常酷。标题是《为什么世界最佳照片初创公司正在倒闭/已经倒闭》。是的。它叫做 the government（政府）。所以我认为这篇文章非常有趣。它讲的是一家名为 Everpix 的基于应用程序的公司。这里的理念是它们会获取你的照片，你知道的，
upload them to their cloud, and then run whatever sort of image processing, classification, you know, upload them to their cloud, and then run whatever sort of image processing, classification, etc, to categorize your photos. And so then give you sort of a search engine for your photos, you can say, you know, Eiffel Tower, and it would just show you photos that you might have taken over several years over several trips to Paris of the Eiffel Tower. So it seems like a cool idea and actually was a good idea. They had a small but very loyal fan base, or I guess customer base, that were paying customers. So they did have revenue.
upload them to their cloud, and then run whatever sort of image processing, classification, you know, upload them to their cloud, and then run whatever sort of image processing, classification, etc, to categorize your photos. And so then give you sort of a search engine for your photos, you can say, you know, Eiffel Tower, and it would just show you photos that you might have taken over several years over several trips to Paris of the Eiffel Tower. So it seems like a cool idea and actually was a good idea. They had a small but very loyal fan base, or I guess customer base, that were paying customers. So they did have revenue.|||将它们上传到他们的云端，然后运行各种图像处理、分类，你知道的，上传到云端，然后运行各种图像处理、分类等程序来对你的照片进行分类。然后为你提供一个类似照片搜索引擎的东西，你可以输入，比如说，“埃菲尔铁塔”，它就会显示你在过去几年里多次去巴黎旅行时拍的埃菲尔铁塔的照片。这听起来是个很酷的主意，实际上也确实是个好主意。他们拥有一个规模虽小但非常忠实的粉丝群，或者我猜是付费客户群。所以他们确实有收入。
And the too-long-don't-read summary is that they basically went out of business. So for two reasons. One is they didn't try to grow their product. So they spent a lot of time focusing on the details and, you know, going through feedback from customers, fixing bugs. And they felt like, you know, the path forward was through, you know, pleasing their current customers as much as possible, which, you know, is very noble, and I can totally empathize with that. But meanwhile, you know, Instagram and Snapchat and these other major blockbuster, you know, photo-based apps
And the too-long-don't-read summary is that they basically went out of business. So for two reasons. One is they didn't try to grow their product. So they spent a lot of time focusing on the details and, you know, going through feedback from customers, fixing bugs. And they felt like, you know, the path forward was through, youening, pleasing their current customers as much as possible, which, you know, is very noble, and I can totally empathize with that. But meanwhile, you know, Instagram and Snapchat and these other major blockbuster, youening, photo-based apps|||而“太长不看”的总结是，他们基本上倒闭了。原因有两个。一个是他们没有试图去发展他们的产品。所以他们花了很多时间专注于细节，你知道的，研究客户的反馈，修复漏洞。他们觉得，你知道的，前进的道路是通过尽可能取悦现有客户，你知道的，这非常高尚，我完全能感同身受。但与此同时，你知道，Instagram、Snapchat 以及其他这些主要的、基于照片的热门应用……
spend more of their time growing the user base. You know, log in with Facebook, get your friends to sign in, more storage space if you get your friends to sign in. They made the app free. I'm talking about their competitors. And so they kind of left this company in the dust. The other interesting thing is this was a startup a few guys who were living in san francisco and they paid themselves each two hundred thousand dollar a year cash salaries and uh this raised a huge stink you know both in the article and in the in the comments there's a really interesting discussion going back and forth but it really makes you think, you know, if you have, I mean, this startup, you know, based on, you know, what I read in the article, they would
spend more of their time growing the user base. You know, log in with Facebook, get your friends to sign in, more storage space if you get your friends to sign in. They made the app free. I'm talking about their competitors. And so they kind of left this company in the dust. The other interesting thing is this was a startup a few guys who were living in san francisco and they paid themselves each two hundred thousand dollar a year cash salaries and uh this raised a huge stink you know both in the article and in the comments there's a really interesting discussion going back and forth but it really makes you think, you know, if you have, I mean, this startup, you know, based on, youening, what I read in the article, they would|||花更多的时间来扩大用户基础。你知道的，用 Facebook 登录，让你的朋友登录，如果朋友登录了就能获得更多存储空间。他们让应用变得免费。我说的是他们的竞争对手。所以他们把这家公司远远甩在了后面。另一个有趣的事情是，这是一家由几个住在旧金山的小伙子创立的初创公司，他们每人给自己开出每年 20 万美元的现金薪水，这引起了轩然大波，你知道的，无论是在文章中还是在评论区，都有非常激烈的来回讨论，但这真的让人深思，你知道的，如果你有——我是说，这家初创公司，你知道的，根据我在文章中读到的，他们……
have failed anyways. So it's like, at least they were able to make a decent salary. But then on the flip side of it, or I guess a great salary, I should say. But on the flip side of it, you know, a lot of people are saying, look, you took, you got $8 million in funding, and you basically took most of it and kept it. The investors should never invest in any company that you guys make, and they're just really upset. And so I thought that that whole dynamic was actually really interesting. Yeah, I mean, I never had heard of this before, this article, but this startup Everpix.
have failed anyways. So it's like, at least they were able to make a decent salary. But then on the flip side of it, or I guess a great salary, I should say. But on the flip side of it, you know, a lot of people are saying, look, you took, you got $8 million in funding, and you basically took most of it and kept it. The investors should never invest in any company that you guys make, and they're just really upset. And so I thought that that whole dynamic was actually really interesting. Yeah, I mean, I never had heard of this before, this article, but this startup Everpix.|||无论如何都会失败的。所以这就好比，至少他们还能赚到一份不错的薪水。但另一方面，或者我应该说是一笔优厚的薪水。但从反面来看，你知道，很多人都在说，听着，你们拿了——你们获得了 800 万美元的资金，而你们基本上把大部分都拿走并据为己有。投资者绝不应该投资你们创建的任何公司，他们真的非常气愤。所以我认为整个动态实际上非常有趣。是的，我的意思是，在看到这篇文章之前，我从未听说过这个，但这家名为 Everpix 的初创公司……
But yeah, I mean mean i thought that was interesting too the like when i was skimming the article the first time i saw it and i saw the salary costs were like so huge and i was like not just like theirs but like in general they were showing like how much they had spent on salaries i was like wow that's like really high and and as we're saying like oh we're paying ourselves like the equivalent you know of other jobs but that's kind of one of the things I've always heard about startups saying is you don't take an equivalent salary. You get a lot less salary because you're essentially donating
But yeah, i mean mean i thought that was interesting too the like when i was skimming the article the first time i saw it and i saw the salary costs were like so huge and i was like not just like theirs but like in general they were showing like how much they had spent on salaries i was like wow that's like really high and and as we're saying like oh we're paying ourselves like the equivalent you know of other jobs but that's kind of one of the things i've always heard about startups saying is you don't take an equivalent salary. You get a lot less salary because you're essentially donating|||但是，是的，我的意思是，我也觉得这很有趣，就像我第一次浏览这篇文章时，看到薪资成本竟然如此之高，我就想——不仅是他们的，而且总体上他们展示了在薪资上花了多少钱，我就想，哇，这真的很高。正如我们所说，哦，我们给自己发相当于其他工作的薪水，但这正是关于初创公司我经常听到的事情之一：你不能拿同等的薪水。你的薪水要少得多，因为你实际上是在捐献……
some portion of your salary to the company in hopes that like, or you're investing it, right? So instead of taking the money out now, you're leaving that money for the company to have more runway to get to the time when it makes tons of money. And then your investment of shares and percentage ownership of the company pays out that much more. Yeah, exactly. I mean, you know, it's true that they had this growth issue where they were, you know, charging customers and it was hard to get new customers. But, you know,
some portion of your salary to the company in hopes that like, or you're investing it, right? So instead of taking the money out now, you're leaving that money for the company to have more runway to get to the time when it makes tons of money. And then your investment of shares and percentage ownership of the company pays out that much more. Yeah, exactly. I mean, you know, it's true that they had this growth issue where they were, youening, charging customers and it was hard to get new customers. But, you know,|||你薪水的一部分给公司，希望——或者说你是在投资它，对吧？所以你不是现在就把钱拿出来，而是把这笔钱留给公司，让公司有更多的时间（资金链）来坚持到它赚大钱的时候。然后你对公司股份和持股比例的投资就会获得更多回报。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，你知道的，确实他们遇到了这种增长问题，他们向客户收费，而且很难获得新客户。但是，你知道，
if they had paid themselves like $ 000 a year instead of 200 000 a year then maybe they'd have another year or two to sort that out but instead they're just like you know they're dead now so i think you have the next news article so yeah 3d printers at the consumer electronics show i should like that is ces stands for yeah i never i never actually looked it up okay i think it's consumer electronics show um so i i'm not super big into consumer electronics i guess like some people are whatever like the latest phones and the latest gadgets um but i it's somewhat interesting and uh i am interested in 3D printers and there was a lot of news about 3D printers at this year's CES. And I was trying to read through what people were saying
if they had paid themselves like $ 000 a year instead of 200 000 a year then maybe they'd have another year or two to sort that out but instead they're just like you know they're dead now so i think you have the next news article so yeah 3d printers at the consumer electronics show i should like that is ces stands for yeah i never i never actually looked it up okay i think it's consumer electronics show um so i i'm not super big into consumer electronics i guess like some people are whatever like the latest phones and the latest gadgets um but i it's somewhat interesting and uh i am interested in 3D printers and there was a lot of news about 3D printers at this year's CES. And I was trying to read through what people were saying|||如果他们每年给自己发比如几千美元（原文疑漏词），而不是每年 20 万美元，那么也许他们会多出一两年时间来解决这个问题，但相反，他们现在就像——你知道的，他们现在倒闭了。所以我想你有下一篇新闻报道？所以，是的，消费电子展上的 3D 打印机，我应该——那是 CES 的缩写，对吧？是的，我从来没去查过。好吧，我想那是 Consumer Electronics Show（消费电子展）。嗯，所以我对消费电子产品并不是特别热衷，我想就像有些人对最新手机和最新小玩意感兴趣一样，嗯，但我觉这有点意思，而且我对 3D 打印机很感兴趣，今年 CES 上有很多关于 3D 打印机的新闻。我一直在试着阅读大家的讨论。
and it's still like, I guess, a relatively younger new industry about what's gonna happen with 3D printers. And it appeals to me because a lot of hardware, a lot of software, and you get to make cool things that you hold in the end. Yeah, definitely. But there's still like a lot of questions around my mind. Like I still see like a lot of software and you get to make cool things that you hold in the end um yeah definitely but um there's still like a lot of questions around my mind like i still see like a lot of
and it's still like, I guess, a relatively younger new industry about what's gonna happen with 3D printers. And it appeals to me because a lot of hardware, a lot of software, and you get to make cool things that you hold in the end. Yeah, definitely. But there's still like a lot of questions around my mind. Like I still see like a lot of software and you get to make cool things that you hold in the end um yeah definitely but um there's still like a lot of questions around my mind. Like I still see like a lot of|||而且我认为 3D 打印机未来会怎样，这仍然是一个相对年轻的新行业。它吸引我的原因是它包含很多硬件、很多软件，最后你还能做出拿在手里的酷炫东西。是的，绝对如此。但我的心中仍然有很多疑问。就像我仍然看到很多软件，而且你最终能做出拿在手里的酷炫东西——嗯，是的，绝对是，但是……我心中仍然有很多疑问。就像我仍然看到很多……
people who think that they will be able to have a lot of use out of 3d printers without doing any cad work um like no designing their own things in 3d programs and maybe that's like 3d programs need to become much easier to use um or like this, there was a lot of scanners coming out. You could scan an everyday object in your house. Like, oh, I like this mug. I'm going to scan this mug, and then I'll have a 3D model of it. So maybe that's one avenue. But they also have the Thingiverse, right?
people who think that they will be able to have a lot of use out of 3d printers without doing any cad work um like no designing their own things in 3d programs and maybe that's like 3d programs need to become much easier to use um or like this, there was a lot of scanners coming out. You could scan an everyday object in your house. Like, oh, I like this mug. I'm going to scan this mug, and then I'll have a 3D model of it. So maybe that's one avenue. But they also have the Thingiverse, right?|||觉得无需进行任何 CAD 工作就能从 3D 打印机中获得巨大用途的人，嗯，比如不需要在 3D 程序中设计自己的东西，也许这就像是 3D 程序需要变得更容易使用一样，嗯，或者像这样，有大量的扫描仪问世。你可以扫描你家里的日常物品。比如，哦，我喜欢这个马克杯。我要扫描这个马克杯，然后我就会拥有它的 3D 模型。所以这可能是一条途径。但他们也有 Thingiverse，对吧？
At least the Thingomatic has the Thingiverse. And it's a huge warehouse of 3D objects. I've done that before, just printed other people people's objects but how far does that get you like if you had bought like your own 3d printer in your house and you didn't know any like programming any you know didn't want to do any cad work 3d work like how would it you that you'd justify the price like of a thousand dollars to only be able to print stuff that's on thingiverse um i don't know i mean so the thing is like the only if the printing itself was an activity like if i would get my son when he's older and the two of us would find crazy things on the internet like on thingiverse like
At least the Thingomatic has the Thingiverse. And it's a huge warehouse of 3D objects. I've done that before, just printed other people people's objects but how far does that get you like if you had bought like your own 3d printer in your house and you didn't know any like programming any you know didn't want to do any cad work 3d work like how would it you that you'd justify the price like of a thousand dollars to only be able to print stuff that's on thingiverse um i don't know i mean so the thing is like the only if the printing itself was an activity like if i would get my son when he's older and the two of us would find crazy things on the internet like on thingiverse like|||至少 Thingomatic 有 Thingiverse。那是一个巨大的 3D 物体仓库。我以前做过那种事，就是打印别人的东西，但这能带你走多远呢？如果你在家里买了自己的 3D 打印机，却不懂任何编程，你知道的，不想做任何 CAD 工作、3D 工作，那你怎么能证明花一千美元买它，却只能打印 Thingiverse 上的东西是物有所值的呢？嗯，我不知道，我的意思是，问题是——只有当打印本身就是一种活动时，比如如果我等我儿子大一点了，我们俩在网上（比如在 Thingiverse 上）找到一些疯狂的东西，比如……
dinosaurs or whatever and print them out uh but yeah you're right a thousand dollars i mean i'm hoping that by then the price will be more like you know three hundred dollars or something yeah so they have three hundred dollar ones now but they tend to involve more tinkering uh bummer so i think yeah maybe maybe in another few years it will be i just like i just wonder like what is and um several of the articles talked about this and the one that'll be in the show notes was more lengthy than most but the you still need the killer app like what is the thing that you want to get a 3d printer to like you would do it get one just to do that um and we haven't really found that yet and maybe once we do it'll be like oh of course like this is awesome um but for now i'm still interested
dinosaurs or whatever and print them out uh but yeah you're right a thousand dollars i mean i'm hoping that by then the price will be more like you know three hundred dollars or something yeah so they have three hundred dollar ones now but they tend to involve more tinkering um so i think yeah maybe maybe in another few years it will be i just like i just wonder like what is and um several of the articles talked about this and the one that'll be in the show notes was more lengthy than most but the you still need the killer app like what is the thing that you want to get a 3d printer to like you would do it get one just to do that um and we haven't really found that yet and maybe once we do it'll be like oh i'm of course like this is awesome um but for now i'm still interested|||恐龙什么的并把它们打印出来，嗯，但是的，你说得对，一千美元——我是说，我希望到那时价格会变成，你知道的，三百美元左右。是的，所以他们现在有三百美元的机型，但它们往往涉及更多的折腾，嗯，所以我想，也许，也许再过几年就会这样了。我只是——我只是在想，什么是……而且有几篇文章讨论了这一点，将在节目笔记中的那篇比大多数文章都要冗长，但你仍然需要“杀手级应用”，比如，你想买一台 3D 打印机是为了做什么，你会为了做这件事专门买一台，嗯，而我们还没有真正找到那个应用，也许一旦我们找到了，就会觉得“哦，当然了，这太棒了”，但就目前而言，我仍然很感兴趣，
because like i like electronics and tinkering and I'm not afraid to do 3D drawing. But the whole it's ready for the masses or it's going prime time or it's a consumer device still eludes me. I'm not sure that that makes any sense. Maybe the 3D printer becomes a way for you to customize, you know, something where like, you know, you'd go to Best Buy and you would buy like a toaster, let's say, but it would just give you like the inside of the toaster. And then you could go to Thingiverse and the toaster manufacturing company has given you like a hundred different shells for the toaster like one that looks like an angry bird or whatever
because like i like electronics and tinkering and I'm not afraid to do 3D drawing. But the whole it's ready for the masses or it's going prime time or it's a consumer device still eludes me. I'm not sure that that makes any sense. Maybe the 3D printer becomes a way for you to customize, you know, something where like, you know, you'd go to Best Buy and you would buy like a toaster, let's say, but it would just give you like the inside of the toaster. And then you could go to Thingiverse and the toaster manufacturing company has given you like a hundred different shells for the toaster like one that looks like an angry bird or whatever|||因为我喜欢电子产品和折腾，我不怕做 3D 绘图。但“它已经准备好面向大众”或“它即将迎来黄金期”或“它是一种消费级设备”的说法仍然让我觉得难以理解。我不知道这是否说得通。也许 3D 打印机成为你定制某种东西的一种方式，你知道的，比如，你去百思买（Best Buy）买个烤面包机，比方说，但它只给你烤面包机内部的零件。然后你可以去 Thingiverse，烤面包机制造商为你提供了上百种不同的烤面包机外壳，比如一个看起来像愤怒的小鸟的外壳什么的，
and you could just print oh angry bird toaster yes what i've always wanted actually you know i think 3d printing something uh like a toaster is probably supremely dangerous well and a bad idea because it's plastic it'll melt yeah yeah yeah that's exactly right but you know what i mean i mean you get where i'm going but but i mean even in that case like i agree like i think 3d printing rapid prototyping has like a use in industry and among engineers and like for rapid prototyping right or like at a store like the best buy you would go buy the they would have a kit of toaster oven innards but instead of stocking 300 different styles of toaster oven they would just stock one or two different insides and then they would 3d print whichever one you chose
and you could just print oh angry bird toaster yes what i've always wanted actually you know i think 3d printing something uh like a toaster is probably supremely dangerous well and a bad idea because it'll melt yeah yeah yeah that's exactly right but you know what i mean i mean you get where i'm going but but i mean even in that case like i agree like i think 3d printing rapid prototyping has like a use in industry and among engineers and like for rapid prototyping right or like at a store like the best buy you would go buy the they would have a kit of toaster oven innards but instead of stocking 300 different styles of toaster oven they would just stock one or two different insides and then they would 3d print whichever one you chose|||然后你就可以直接打印出——哦，愤怒的小鸟烤面包机！是的，这正是我一直想要的。实际上，你知道，我认为 3D 打印像烤面包机这样的东西可能极其危险，嗯，而且是个坏主意，因为它会融化。是的，是的，是的，完全正确。但你知道我的意思，我是说你明白我的意思。但是，即使在那种情况下，我也同意，我认为 3D 打印快速原型在工业界和工程师当中有其用途，比如用于快速原型设计，对吧？或者像在百思买这样的商店里，你去买——他们会有一套烤面包机内部零件包，但他们不会备货 300 种不同风格的烤面包机，而只会备货一两种不同的内部零件，然后他们会 3D 打印你选择的任何外壳。
yeah exactly right but that doesn't still explain like why i would need one at home unless i was gonna like change toaster shells every couple months yeah yeah but you know maybe that's maybe that's where it goes like for example you know uh you don't really need a paint mixer at home but you know i'm really happy when you know i go to lowe's and they have one but paint mixers aren't all talked about at ces and people saying oh this is the wave of the future well maybe they were. It's CES 1932. Okay. Anyways, 3D printers are cool. I guess my point is maybe it's not, you know, the end goal really isn't your home.
yeah exactly right but that doesn't still explain like why i would need one at home unless i was gonna like change toaster shells every couple months yeah yeah but you know maybe that's maybe that's where it goes like for example you know uh you don't really need a paint mixer at home but you know i'm really happy when you know i go to lowe's and they have one but paint mixers aren't all talked about at ces and people saying oh this is the wave of the future well maybe they were. It's CES 1932. Okay. Anyways, 3D printers are cool. I guess my point is maybe it's not, you know, the end goal really isn't your home.|||是的，完全正确，但这仍然不能解释为什么我需要在家里备一台，除非我打算每隔几个月就换一次烤面包机外壳。是的，是的，但你知道，也许这——也许这就是它的发展方向，比如，你知道，你家里其实不需要油漆搅拌机，但你知道，当我得知我去劳氏（Lowe's）时他们有这个，我真的很高兴，但人们不会在 CES 上到处谈论油漆搅拌机，然后说“哦，这是未来的潮流”。好吧，也许他们谈过，那是 1932 年的 CES。好吧。不管怎样，3D 打印机很酷。我想我的意思是，也许它并不是——你知道的，最终目标真的不是进入你的家庭。
You know, like it's just for, like right now it's mainly for geeks. And geeks like doing things themselves. But, you know, maybe the end goal is, you know know to put it in a best buy like you're saying that's true no i mean to me it's extremely interesting but i also like making my own furniture and building circuits and so i mean like it makes sense to me for me i just like i guess i feel like i'm atypical in that respect that most other people aren't like that where they don't want to do that kind of stuff so we'll see but if you use if you're interested in 3d printers you should check out some of the cool stuff that was shown off at
You know, like it's just for, like right now it's mainly for geeks. And geeks like doing things themselves. But, you know, maybe the end goal is, you know to put it in a best buy like you're saying that's true no i mean to me it's extremely interesting but i also like making my own furniture and building circuits and so i mean like it makes sense to me for me i just like i guess i feel like i'm atypical in that respect that most other people aren't like that where they don't want to do that kind of stuff so we'll see but if you use if you're interested in 3d printers you should check out some of the cool stuff that was shown off at|||你知道，这只是——就像现在它主要面向极客。而极客喜欢自己动手做事情。但是，你知道，也许最终目标是，你知道的，把它放在百思买里，就像你刚才说的。那是真的。不，我的意思是，对我来说它极其有趣，但我也喜欢自己做家具和搭建电路，所以我的意思是，这对我来说很有意义，对我而言，我只是——我想我在这方面觉得我是个非典型人物，大多数其他人并非如此，他们不想做那种事情。所以我们拭目以待，但如果你使用——如果你对 3D 打印机感兴趣，你应该去看看在……上展示的一些炫酷产品。
ces yeah definitely yeah 3d prints are actually really fun and learning like uh i use blender but whether you use blender or uh was it solid there's one called solid some solid work scad solid cad okay regardless of which one you use they're all uh they're all pretty cool you can Was it Solid? There's one called Solid something. Solid Works. Or SCAD. Solid CAD. Regardless of which one you use, they're all pretty cool, and you can make some really fun stuff. Yep. All right. Okay, so I got a pretty cool article. It's Top 25 Oddball Interview Questions, and it's a good lead-in you know, our nice little segue, you know, mid, mid show topic that we're going to keep hidden for suspense reasons. But, uh, but yeah, so this website, uh, you know can look around in Glassdoor and they'll give you like superficial
ces yeah definitely yeah 3d prints are actually really fun and learning like uh i use blender but whether you use blender or uh was it solid there's one called solid some solid work scad solid cad okay regardless of which one you use they're all uh they're all pretty cool you can Was it Solid? There's one called Solid something. Solid Works. Or SCAD. Solid CAD. Regardless of which one you use, they're all pretty cool, and you can make some really fun stuff. Yep. All right. Okay, so I got a pretty cool article. It's Top 25 Oddball Interview Questions, and it's a good lead-in you know, our nice little segue, you know, mid, mid show topic that we're going to keep hidden for suspense reasons. But, uh, but yeah, so this website, uh, you know can look around in Glassdoor and they'll give you like superficial|||CES 上展出的产品。是的，绝对的。是的，3D 打印实际上真的很有趣，而且学习——呃，我用 Blender，但无论你用 Blender 还是呃，是 Solid 吗？有一个叫 Solid 什么的，SolidWorks，或者 OpenSCAD，SolidCAD。好吧，不管你用哪一个，它们都——它们都挺酷的，你可以制作一些非常有趣的东西。是 Solid 吗？有一个叫 Solid 什么的。SolidWorks。或者 OpenSCAD。SolidCAD。不管你用哪一个，它们都挺酷的，你可以制作一些非常有趣的东西。Yep。好的。好的，我有一篇相当酷的文章。它是《前 25 个奇葩面试问题》，这是一个很好的引子，你知道的，我们精彩的小过渡，你知道的，节目中段的、为了悬念我们要暂时保密的节目话题。但是，嗯，但是是的，所以这个网站，嗯，你知道的，可以在 Glassdoor 上浏览，他们会给你提供肤浅的……
information on different jobs different companies salary expectation things like that but then after you get a certain you know way through the site they say oh hey you know you have to give a little to take a little more and so they have you log in through like their account or Facebook, et cetera, and put in some anonymous statistics about your job, which, you know, they use to sort of, you know, keep the whole thing running. But now they've, you know, they've become pretty popular among, you know, job seekers or career enthusiasts, I guess. And so they have spun off this blog. And on this blog, they do a variety of different things.
information on different jobs different companies salary expectation things like that but then after you get a certain you know way through the site they say oh hey you know you have to give a little to take a little more and so they have you log in through like their account or Facebook, et cetera, and put in some anonymous statistics about your job, which, you know, they use to sort of, you know, keep the whole thing running. But now they've, you know, they've become pretty popular among, youening, job seekers or career enthusiasts, I guess. And so they have spun off this blog. And on this blog, they do a variety of different things.|||关于不同工作、不同公司的薪资期望等信息，但在你浏览了一定程度之后，他们会说，哦，嘿，你知道的，你必须付出一点才能获取更多，所以他们让你通过他们的账户或 Facebook 等登录，并输入一些关于你工作的匿名统计数据，你知道的，他们用这些来让整个网站持续运转。但现在他们已经——你知道的，他们已经在求职者或职业爱好者中变得相当受欢迎了，我想。所以他们衍生出了这个博客。在这个博客上，他们做各种不同的事情。
Every year, they have the top companies to work for, the craziest work environment, et cetera. And this is a top 25 oddball questions. And I've seen a lot of sites like this. And most of them focus on questions that they ask like project managers on the grounds that you need to be able to sort of think critically and think mathematically so you see a lot of these like this one in particular says how many cows are in canada how many quarters would you need need to reach the height of the empire state building
Every year, they have the top companies to work for, the craziest work environment, et cetera. And this is a top 25 oddball questions. And I've seen a lot of sites like this. And most of them focus on questions that they ask like project managers on the grounds that you need to be able to sort of think critically and think mathematically so you see a lot of these like this one in particular says how many cows are in canada how many quarters would you need need to reach the height of the empire state building|||每年，他们都会评选出最佳雇主、最疯狂的工作环境等等。而这是“前 25 个奇葩问题”。我见过很多这样的网站。它们大多数关注的是向项目经理之类的人提出的问题，理由是你需要能够进行批判性思考和数学思考，所以你会看到很多这样的问题，比如这个特别指出：加拿大有多少头牛？你需要多少枚 25 美分硬币才能达到帝国大厦的高度？
um you know i've heard like how many so those are i don't see those are odd airplanes stuff like that those are all the same same type of question or how much extra gasoline would the united states consume if there was a law passed that all headlights had to be on all the time on cars when they were driving right right and most of the time what it comes down to is you have this like very complex dynamical system and you just need to start with like trying to simplify it as much as you can and you know just like for example the ping pong question you start by thinking you know how many ping pong balls can you fit in like a one meter cube yeah like basically it's just all about estimation but it's also proves on some of them you need to know a little bit more like for instance the one i said like headlights being on like that there's an inefficiency in powering a
um you know i've heard like how many so those are i don't see those are odd airplanes stuff like that those are all the same same type of question or how much extra gasoline would the united states consume if there was a law passed that all headlights had to be on all the time on cars when they were driving right right and most of the time what it comes down to is you have this like very complex dynamical system and you just need to start with like trying to simplify it as much as you can and you know just like for example the ping pong question you start by thinking you know how many ping pong balls can you fit in like a one meter cube yeah like basically it's just all about estimation but it's also proves on some of them you need to know a little bit more like for instance the one i said like headlights being on like that there's an inefficiency in powering a|||嗯，你知道，我听过诸如“多少”之类的问题——所以那些——我不认为那是奇怪的，比如飞机之类的问题，那些全都是同一种类型的问题，或者“如果通过一项法律，规定汽车在行驶时所有车头灯必须一直开着，美国会多消耗多少额外的汽油？”对吧，对吧？大多数情况下，归根结底就是你面对这样一个非常复杂的动态系统，你只需要从尽你所能去简化它开始，你知道的，就像乒乓球问题一样，你首先考虑的是，你知道，一个一立方米的立方体内能放下多少个乒乓球？是的，基本上这完全是关于估算的，但也证明了在某些问题上你需要了解更多，比如我刚才说的那个关于车头灯一直开着的例子，为车头灯供电存在效率低下问题，
generator to have the headlight on that causes you to use more gas or whatever in addition to estimating how many cars are in the u.s and how much do they drive and how much gas do they consume right yeah exactly so yeah but you should be ready to answer those like if uh like that's a really common style of question to estimate something really big that there's no way you can actually know the answer to i don't think that's oddball like i think you should really know that if you're going to do any sort of engineering interview yeah that yeah definitely don't uh just say like a hundred or something like that you know i mean what they want to know and we'll talk about this more as uh we go on but but uh what they really want to know are just like uh the process and like your methodology yeah i think that's it like knowing you can take a
generator to have the headlight on that causes you to use more gas or whatever in addition to estimating how many cars are in the u.s and how much do they drive and how much gas do they consume right yeah exactly so yeah but you should be ready to answer those like if uh like that's a really common style of question to estimate something really big that there's no way you can actually know the answer to i don't think that's oddball like i think you should really know that if you're going to do any sort of engineering interview yeah that yeah definitely don't uh just say like a hundred or something like that you know i mean what they want to know and we'll talk about this more as uh we go on but but uh what they really want to know are just like uh the process and like your methodology yeah i think that's it like knowing you can take a|||这会导致你消耗更多的汽油等等，此外还要估算美国有多少辆汽车、它们行驶了多少里程、消耗了多少汽油，对吧？是的，完全正确。所以，是的，但你应该准备好回答这些问题，如果——就像那种非常常见的提问风格：估算一个你根本不可能知道确切答案的庞大数值。我不认为这很奇葩，我认为如果你要参加任何工程面试，你真的应该懂这些。是的，那——绝对不要，呃，随口说个“一百”之类的数字，你知道的，我的意思是他们想知道的是——随着我们的深入，我们会对此讨论更多——但呃，他们真正想知道的只是，呃，你的思考过程和方法论。是的，我想就是这样，知道如何能将一个……
seemingly impossible question and break it down piece by piece yeah exactly exactly and each so did you go through these questions do you know so why is a tennis ball fuzzy um why is a tennis i'm assuming it has something to do with the way it bounces to keep it from rotating or something. I actually thought it was to slow it down or something. Yeah, to keep it from going too fast. Oh, is that the real answer? To level the playing board. No, I don't know.
seemingly impossible question and break it down piece by piece yeah exactly exactly and each so did you go through these questions do you know so why is a tennis ball fuzzy um why is a tennis i'm assuming it has something to do with the way it bounces to keep it from rotating or something. I actually thought it was to slow it down or something. Yeah, to keep it from going too fast. Oh, is that the real answer? To level the playing board. No, I don't know.|||看似不可能回答的问题拆解成各个小部分。是的，完全正确，完全正确。那么，你浏览过这些问题吗？你知道为什么网球是起毛的吗？嗯，为什么网球——我猜这与它的弹跳方式有关，可以防止它旋转什么的。我其实以为它是为了减速什么的。是的，为了防止它飞得太快。哦，那是真正的答案吗？为了让比赛更公平。不，我不知道。
There's actually not answers on these. They're all ball questions. Do you believe in Bigfoot? Do you believe in Bigfoot? No, that's one of these. Okay, we can stop stop so you should go that's more ridiculous um so so on interviewing what are some what's that on interviewing so what are some like good tips for people like if they're going to interview so so this is sort of
There's actually not answers on these. They're all ball questions. Do you believe in Bigfoot? Do you believe in Bigfoot? No, that's one of these. Okay, we can stop stop so you should go that's more ridiculous um so so on interviewing what are some what's that on interviewing so what are some like good tips for people like if they're going to interview so so this is sort of|||这里面其实没有答案。这些全都是关于球的问题。你相信大脚怪吗？你相信大脚怪吗？不，这是其中之一。好吧，我们可以停下了，所以你应该继续——这更荒谬。嗯，所以——关于面试，有哪些——那是关于面试的什么？——对于要去面试的人来说，有哪些好的建议？所以，这有点……
deviating from the normal show yeah we're definitely going to get to unix commands but uh as you might expect, that's not an entire language, although maybe it should be. But we wanted to add a little bit of spice, a little bit of interesting content. And so we decided to think, what does it take to really ace an interview?
deviating from the normal show yeah we're definitely going to get to unix commands but uh as you might expect, that's not an entire language, although maybe it should be. But we wanted to add a little bit of spice, a little bit of interesting content. And so we decided to think, what does it take to really ace an interview?|||偏离了常规节目。是的，我们肯定会讲到 Unix 命令，但是，正如你所料，那并不是一门完整的语言，尽管也许它应该是一门。但我们想增加一点趣味，加点有趣的内容。所以我们决定思考一下，要在面试中大获全胜需要具备什么？
Now, of course, you have to know what you're talking about you can't have a degree in computer science and then try to ace an interview for the legal team right i mean it's just not going to happen but you know with that said there are um there's a there's there's a whole process to interviewing and to being interviewed. And, you know, the reality is that sadly enough, there's some people who fail at that process, despite the fact that are extremely qualified. And it works the other way as well. And so understanding the interview process is a big step towards, you know, either, you know, changing careers, or to interviewing other people for roles within your company.
Now, of course, you have to know what you're talking about you can't have a degree in computer science and then try to ace an interview for the legal team right i mean it's just not going to happen but you know with that said there are um there's a there's a whole process to interviewing and to being interviewed. And, you know, the reality is that sadly enough, there's some people who fail at that process, despite the fact that are extremely qualified. And it works the other way as well. And so understanding the interview process is a big step towards, you know, either, you know, changing careers, or to interviewing other people for roles within your company.|||当然，你必须对你讨论的内容有所了解——你不能拿着计算机科学学位却试图通过法务团队的面试，对吧？我的意思是，这根本不可能发生。但话虽如此，面试和被面试其实是一个完整的流程。而且，你知道的，现实情况是，可悲的是，有些人尽管资质极高，却在这个流程中失败了。反过来也是如此。因此，理解面试流程是迈向——你知道的，无论是改变职业道路，还是在公司内部为各个岗位面试他人——的重要一步。
Or graduating from college and trying to get your first job. Yeah, yeah, yeah, definitely. There's no doubt. And we'll mostly be talking about, we'll go from general to specific, but in the beginning it'll be applicable to everything. But then further along we'll start talking specifically if you have what's called a technical interview, which is an interview where they're going to ask you to solve problems or you know do programming in the interview which not every interview is that way and if possible you should try to find out in advance if it will be a technical interview or not yeah definitely
Or graduating from college and trying to get your first job. Yeah, yeah, yeah, definitely. There's no doubt. And we'll mostly be talking about, we'll go from general to specific, but in the beginning it'll be applicable to everything. But then further along we'll start talking specifically if you have what's called a technical interview, which is an interview where they're going to ask you to solve problems or you know do programming in the interview which not every interview is that way and if possible you should try to find out in advance if it will be a technical interview or not yeah definitely|||或者刚从大学毕业并试图找到你的第一份工作。对，对，对，绝对的。毫无疑问。我们接下来主要会讨论的是——我们会从一般性讲到具体性，但在开始时，它将适用于所有情况。但随后我们会深入探讨，如果你遇到所谓的“技术面试”该怎么办，这是一种要求你在面试中解决问题或编写程序的面试——并非每次面试都是这样的，如果可能的话，你应该提前弄清楚这是否会是一场技术面试。是的，绝对应该。
that's a really good point it's kind of sad but i considered college as a career like when i was thinking in my head switching careers i guess because i was in college for so long that oh okay it's pretty bad anyways so um you want to go first sure so i mean like the first and maybe this is like like i said they're general and therefore probably more obvious in the beginning but you should read up about the company you're interviewing with i mean it's kind of like bad but i've done interviews where the person comes in as kind of like so what do you what do you guys do and they don't mean like what kind of work specifically do i do because i've already said that they're like just asking like in general what does the company do or like what products they make um and it's like yeah okay that's like
that's a really good point it's kind of sad but i considered college as a career like when i was thinking in my head switching careers i guess because i was in college for so long that oh okay it's pretty bad anyways so um you want to go first sure so i mean like the first and maybe this is like like i said they're general and therefore probably more obvious in the beginning but you should read up about the company you're interviewing with i mean it's kind of bad but i've done interviews where the person comes in as kind of like so what do you what do you guys do and they don't mean like what kind of work specifically do i do because i've already said that they're like just asking like in general what does the company do or like what products they make um and it's like yeah okay that's like|||这真是一个很好的观点。这有点悲哀，但我曾把上大学当成一种职业——当我脑子里在考虑转行时，我想可能是因为我在大学待的时间太久了，以至于——哦，好吧，反正这挺糟糕的。所以，嗯，你想先说吗？当然。所以我的意思是，第一点，也许这就像我说的，它们是一般性的，因此在开始时可能更显而易见，但你应该事先了解你要去面试的公司。我的意思是，这有点糟糕，但我做过这样的面试：应聘者走进来，有点像“嗯，你们——你们到底是做什么的？”他们指的不是我具体做什么工作，因为我已经说过那一点了，他们只是在泛泛地问这家公司是做什么的，或者生产什么产品，嗯，这就好像，是的，好吧，这就像是……
you didn't look us up on the internet uh you know like this is not good um so definitely read up and know about you know like what are the most famous products they do or the things in the news and specifically like if it's a big company it's good to find out like at that branch what do they work on so like if your company has like you know makes furniture and in one city they make couches and in one city they make desks you know if you can find that out like that's also more helpful because then if you're interviewing in the city where they make desks you're probably talking to people who work on making desks and then you know you can ask specifically about that kind of stuff. Yeah, definitely. I mean, so Patrick and I have been interviewees several times. We've interviewed
you didn't look us up on the internet uh you know like this is not good um so definitely read up and know about you know like what are the most famous products they do or the things in the news and specifically like if it's a big company it's good to find out like at that branch what do they work on so like if your company has like you know makes furniture and in one city they make couches and in one city they make desks you know if you can find that out like that's also more helpful because then if you're interviewing in the city where they make desks you're probably talking to people who work on making desks and then you know you can ask specifically about that kind of stuff. Yeah, definitely. I mean, so Patrick and I have been interviewees several times. We've interviewed|||你根本没有在网上查过我们，呃，你知道的，这不太好。嗯，所以一定要提前阅读并了解，比如他们最著名的产品是什么，或者新闻里报道了什么。特别是如果是一家大公司，最好能弄清楚在那个分公司他们具体在做什么项目。所以，比如如果你们公司——你知道的——生产家具，在一个城市他们生产沙发，在另一个城市他们生产书桌，如果你能查到这一点，也会更有帮助，因为如果你在生产书桌的那个城市面试，你很可能是在和负责生产书桌的人交谈，然后你就可以针对这类事情进行具体提问。是的，绝对如此。我的意思是，帕特里克（Patrick）和我作为面试者经历过好几次了。我们面试过……
a lot of people. Probably between the two of us, we've interviewed over 150 people, just estimating. So, and one of the big things is you know there's some people who are there um but they don't really want the job or you know they find out they don't want the job by the time they get to your interview if they've had other prior interviews the same day and so um as an interviewer just because of the statistics it's very easy to sort of lump someone into the pool of people where you just feel like this, like they're just not interested. Right. Because there are a lot of people who aren't interested, um, but are interviewing for other reasons or who knows. Right. So, um, yeah, you definitely, uh, as a interviewee, you want to understand the company
很多人。估计我们两个加起来面试过150多个人。所以，其中一个很大的问题是，你知道有些人来面试，但他们其实并不想要这份工作，或者你知道，如果他们在同一天参加过其他之前的面试，当他们来到你的面试时，他们会发现自己并不想要这份工作，所以作为面试官，仅仅从统计数据来看，很容易把某人归入那种让你觉得他们根本不感兴趣的人群中。没错。因为确实有很多不感兴趣的人，为了其他原因来面试，或者谁知道呢。所以，是的，作为面试者，你绝对想要了解这家公司
and be enthusiastic. And I mean, the reality is if you don't understand what that company does then uh like how can you really want to work there it doesn't really add up but yet you find tons of people who uh who are in that category so that's definitely where you want to do your homework um so another one is you uh it's really important to be confident and not to be intimidated so or at least to act confident yeah yeah especially when you're doing a technical interview uh just kind of keep telling yourself or just remember uh meditate on this that you know the interviewer um you know he might have asked that same question to say 50 other people, right? Or if he hasn't, he's preparing to ask that question to another 20 or 30 people, right? So he's going
并且表现出热情。我的意思是，现实情况是，如果你不了解这家公司是做什么的，那你怎么能真正想在那里工作呢？这根本说不通。但你还是会发现大量处于这种类别的人，所以这绝对是需要做好功课的地方。另一个重点是，保持自信非常重要，不要感到胆怯，或者至少要表现得自信。特别是当你进行技术面试时，不断告诉自己或者记住这一点，冥想一下：面试官可能已经对其他50个人问过同样的问题了，对吧？或者如果他还没问，他正准备向另外20或30个人问这个问题，对吧？所以他将
to be an expert on that question. And he might have seen just about everything that people have thrown at a certain question. Like the guy who asks the, how many ping pong balls can you, you know, does it take to fill up a 747, right? Like he's probably heard a hundred different answers. And so, you know, nothing is really gonna phase him. And he's always, the interviewer is always gonna seem like one step ahead of you because they are one step ahead of you.
成为那个问题的专家。对于某个特定的问题，他可能已经见过人们给出的各种各样的答案了。就像那个问“要把一架747填满，需要多少个乒乓球？”的人一样，他大概听过一百种不同的答案。所以，没有什么能真正难倒他。而且面试官总是会显得比你领先一步，因为他们确实比你领先一步。
They're in fact, they're more than one step ahead of you, right? So don't let this intimidate you. The reality is, you know, you can go through a process, and while it feels like you're kind of struggling, what you're really doing as an interviewee is solving the problem, and you're solving the problem under distress because there's a lot on the line and there's a lot of time pressure. And, uh, so that's not a bad thing. You know, I think that there's a, a lot of people get,
事实上，他们比你领先不止一步，对吧？所以不要让这一点吓倒你。现实情况是，你可以经历整个流程，虽然感觉你有点在挣扎，但作为面试者，你真正做的是在解决问题，而且是在压力下解决问题，因为有很多东西悬而未决，而且时间非常紧迫。所以，这并不是一件坏事。我知道，很多人会
get way too nervous in an interview setting. Uh, as soon as, you know, they start saying things that are on the wrong track, you know, don't hesitate to throw things out there that are bad and then, you know, come back to a better place and to a better solution you know so um that's my two cents on that and we're gonna have to speed this up a little or this will be the whole episode but um yeah i mean the other thing is like always try to answer what they're asking but then try to finish it out right so say like okay first here i'm describing you like how i'm gonna attempt to solve it then like oh here I'm describing you like how I'm going to attempt to solve it. Then like, oh, here I'm writing code. Okay, now I'm done with my code.
在面试环境中变得过分紧张。一旦他们开始说一些偏离方向的话，不要犹豫，把不好的想法抛出来，然后回到更好的地方和更好的解决方案。这就是我对此的一点浅见，我们得稍微加快一点速度，否则这就成了一整集了。但另一个要点是，总是试着回答他们提出的问题，然后试着把它完整地表达出来。比如说，“好，首先在这里我向你描述我将如何尝试解决它”，然后，“好，在这里我向你描述我将如何尝试解决它。接下来，好，这里我在写代码。好的，现在我的代码写完了。”
Don't be like, oh, okay, I'm finished. Say like, okay, now I'm going to test my code. Now I'm going to, you know, like try to evaluate if I've made any errors. And really going through that whole process is useful as well. And then, you know, make sure also like it's, some people don't think about this,
不要说，“好，我完成了。”而是说，“好，现在我要测试我的代码。现在我要，你知道的，试着评估我是否犯了任何错误。”经历整个过程同样是非常有用的。然后，确保也要注意到这一点——有些人不会考虑到这一点，
but you will almost always get asked at the end of your interview. Do you have any questions? And like it seems kind of silly and oh, this doesn't really matter. They're just asking me like to be friendly. You know, do I have any questions? But in reality, like at least this is what I've always been told. And it seems to work. People think positively about themselves.
但在面试结束时，你几乎总是会被问到：“你有什么问题吗？”这听起来有点傻，觉得这并不重要，他们只是为了显得友好才问我“我有什么问题吗？”但实际上，至少这是我一直被告知的，而且这似乎很管用。人们倾向于对自己产生积极的想法。
So if the interviewer is talking about themselves, they're thinking positive thoughts. So they'll think positive thoughts about the interview. And it sounds really like psychological or something. But if you think about it makes sense. So if you ask a question, like, what's your favorite part of working here? Or, you know, what do you like most about, you know, being a software engineer at Intel or wherever it is, then the person is going to like say something that they're passionate about. And then that's what they're going to remember about your interview. And it seems really silly, and maybe it doesn't matter.
因此，如果面试官在谈论他们自己，他们就会产生积极的想法。所以他们会对这次面试产生积极的看法。这听起来真的很像心理学之类的。但仔细想想，这是有道理的。所以如果你问一个问题，比如“你在这里工作最喜欢的部分是什么？”或者“作为英特尔或其他什么地方的软件工程师，你最喜欢什么？”，那么这个人就会说出他们充满激情的事情。然后这就会成为他们对你面试的记忆点。这听起来真的很傻，也许这并不重要。
And if you have actual real legitimate questions, you can, of course, feel free to ask those as well. But at least ask some question or questions, even if you've asked other interviewers the same question that day. Yeah, definitely. Yeah. I mean, that's another good point. And then we'll try to, as Patrick said, speed this up. But basically, you know, you'll often have many interviews, you know, within one day.
如果你有真正合理的问题，当然也可以随时问出来。但至少要问一个或几个问题，即使你在那天已经问过其他面试官同样的问题。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，这也是一个好点子。然后正如帕特里克所说，我们会试着加快速度。但基本上，你知道的，你经常会在一天之内进行很多次面试。
Like you'll have many interviewers that are coming and going for a particular interview. And they, by design, they don't collaborate. So you know, if you flub the first interview, because the morning and you just, just didn't work out. Don't let that ruin your whole day, right? Go into the second interview with a blank slate, because it is a blank slate. I mean, if, if the company like, you know, has people sort of collaborate from from one, you know, session to the next, then they're not going to end up with five sources of honest feedback, right? So most people don't do that. And so it's okay to flub an interview or like one part of an interview. So let's get to maybe more of the specific, like, technical parts of the interview.
比如你会有很多不同的面试官在特定的面试中进进出出。按照设计，他们是不会互相沟通的。所以你知道，如果你把第一场面试搞砸了，因为那是早晨，而你状态不对，不要让那毁了你的一整天，对吧？带着一张白纸的心态进入第二场面试，因为它本来就是一张白纸。我的意思是，如果公司会让人们从一个环节到下一个环节进行某种形式的交流，那么他们最终就不会得到五份诚实的反馈意见了，对吧？所以大多数人不会那样做。因此，搞砸一场面试或者面试的一部分是没有关系的。所以让我们转向更多具体的、技术性的面试环节吧。
One big part is to do a lot of open source or at least open source your own work, especially, you know, if you're not in industry yet, if you're in academia or if you're just a student, you know, graduating from college, you know, take your assignments and kind of polish them, maybe put some comments and whatnot, and then open source them, right? Even just put them on GitHub, just so you have an account and a presence, you know, I think that's, that's a really good idea. And it sort of like, gets you familiar with some of the tools that you'll be using when you go to industry. Definitely. It's also important to even if you are fresh out of college or you've been out of college for a little bit longer to go through and like kind of from scratch go through the common data structures and algorithms that that you're likely to be asked about and the important thing here is from scratch like it sounds kind of silly but like without
其中很大一部分是多做开源，或者至少把你的工作开源，特别是如果你还不在业界，如果你在学术界，或者如果你只是一名刚从大学毕业的学生，把你的作业整理一下，可能加一些注释之类的，然后把它们开源，对吧？甚至只是把它们放在GitHub上，让你拥有一个账号和存在感，我觉得这真的是一个好主意。这有点像让你熟悉一些将来进入业界时会用到的工具。绝对的。同样重要的是，即使你是刚毕业的大学生，或者毕业已经有一段时间了，也要从头到尾复习一下常见的数据结构和算法，这些很可能会被问到。这里重要的一点是“从头到尾”——听起来可能有点傻，但
looking it up without doing it or looking it up once and then you know trying to implement it because there's one thing to like read about something and say like oh okay now i know you know about binary tree traversal and it's another to actually sit down and write the code for it and if you're in a coding interview you're gonna have to write the code for it and it's best if you've written the code for it recently and so it's a little easier to do so things like binary trees and tree traversals sorting you need to know at least you know one in login algorithm that you can do from scratch the graph algorithms recursion dynamic programming and then another big one in college it's not stressed, but if you go to any sort of large-scale internet company,
不要去查资料，要么看一次然后试着去实现它。因为阅读某种东西是一回事，比如“哦，好的，现在我知道二叉树遍历了”，而坐下来真正写出它的代码则是另一回事。如果你在进行代码面试，你将不得不写出代码，如果你最近刚好写过代码，那就最好不过了，这样会更容易做到。所以像二叉树、树的遍历、排序，你需要至少掌握一个能够从头到尾写出来的O(log n)算法，图算法，递归，动态规划。另一个在大学里不太强调、但如果你去任何大型互联网公司都会被问到的重点是，
knowing about hashing and hash maps, like, a lot. Almost every question at an internet-based company seems like it could have a solution that uses a hash map. Yeah, you're absolutely right. You're absolutely right. Have you heard of locality-sensitive hashing? I mean, no no but the words in english make sense to me okay yeah we'll have to talk about it some other time but that that is
了解哈希和哈希映射（Hash Map），问得非常多。在一家互联网公司，几乎每个问题似乎都可以用使用哈希映射的方案来解决。是的，你说得完全对。你说得完全对。你听说过局部敏感哈希吗？我是说，没有，但英文单词我能听懂。好吧，我们改天再聊这个，但那个
like the topic du jour it seems like everybody is um like that seems to be like the internet the interview question of the week or something on everyone's calendar oh interesting interesting but but yeah but patrick's absolutely right i mean you want to understand the fundamentals and uh and yeah it doesn't hurt to code them up i mean you think about it um you see a lot of people like practicing martial arts like kung fu or taekwondo or whatever and they do the same kick over and over again every day and a lot of that is kind of muscle memory it's like supposed to be instinctive. And so there's a number of competition sites like Topcoder, Kaggle, Project Oiler. And if you go to these sites
就像时下的热门话题，似乎每个人都在讨论，那似乎成了每个人日程表上的“本周面试题”或类似的东西。哦，很有意思，很有意思！但帕特里克说得完全对，你需要理解基础知识，并且，是的，把它们写成代码并没有坏处。你想想，你看到很多人练习武术，比如功夫、跆拳道什么的，他们每天一遍又一遍地做同一个踢腿动作，其中很大一部分是为了形成肌肉记忆，它应该成为一种本能。因此，有很多竞赛网站，比如Topcoder、Kaggle、Project Euler。如果你去这些网站
and you do a lot of their practice problems or compete in some of their student or professional competitions, then you will build that sort of muscle memory for your brain. And you will be able to sort of muscle memory for your brain. And you will be able to sort of instinctively, you won't just, someone won't just tell you some question and you'll say three.
做大量的练习题，或者参加他们的一些学生或专业竞赛，你就会为你的大脑建立起那种肌肉记忆。你将能够为你的大脑建立肌肉记忆。你将能够本能地——别人不会只是随便问你一个问题，然后你回答“三”。
It doesn't work like that. But you'll instinctively jump to a certain set of tools that will at least get you in the right direction. Yep. And it is worth noting too, like even if you do programming day to day and like it's arbitrary as it seems to do these silly questions,
事情不是这样的。但你会本能地运用一套特定的工具，至少能把你引向正确的方向。是的。值得一提的是，即使你每天都在编程，尽管做这些愚蠢的问题看起来很随机，
that is what these companies have chosen to do to screen people. And so you either got to kind of sign up to do it or just decide you're not going to work at one of those companies. So like, you know, in my day to day job, I don't ever implement a binary tree from scratch. But if I know I'm interviewing at a company that asks these kind of questions, I should study that or decide that I'm just not going to bother. Because it's also I've heard stories, and we're moving into maybe the section
但这就是这些公司选择用来筛选人的方式。所以你要么选择接受并去做，要么就决定不去那些公司工作。所以，你知道的，在我日常的工作中，我从来没有从头实现过二叉树。但我知道我要去一家会问这类问题的公司面试，我就应该去学习它，或者决定不去理会它。因为我也听过一些故事，我们现在要进入
where we talk about some bad stories. But I've heard stories before people saying, like, I know how to do that, but I'm not going to do it for you. That basically like that's so elementary, like it's a waste of time. Like, let's talk about other things. Um, and yeah, so that doesn't work out that well. So like, you gotta be prepared to like, it sounds bad, but like play the game that the interviewer wants you to play. Um, even if you think you're above that um yeah it's a really good point i mean the reality is is it you know it doesn't matter whether you're 25 or 52 uh you know if you go to a technical interview you're gonna have to know binary trees hash maps sorting etc yeah an interviewer knows there's a tool that does that already yeah i mean they know that as
谈论一些糟糕经历的部分了。但我以前听过有人说：“我知道怎么做，但我不会为你做，因为这太基础了，简直是浪费时间，让我们谈谈别的吧。”是的，所以那种态度结果往往不太好。所以你必须做好准备去玩面试官希望你玩的“游戏”，听起来可能不太好，即使你觉得自己高人一等。是的，这真的说得很好。现实情况是，无论你是25岁还是52岁，如果你去参加技术面试，你都必须了解二叉树、哈希映射、排序等。是的，面试官知道已经有现成的工具可以做到这一点。
well but like that's not the point yeah yeah like the right answer isn't oh i'll use the binary tree code off the internet it's not gonna work yeah so um so uh you want to cover best and worst yeah so well best moment i don't know if i have a best moment other than like ever not completely flunking out at someone's question but um my worst moment what about a best interviewer moment like did you have a moment where you interviewed somebody no it was really profound or anything okay no but i do have a worst one i was in an interview where i was gonna have several interviews that day i think like four or five and it was like the first or second one. And this person asked me like a really open-ended question, like one of these kind of like estimation style questions.
是的，我的意思是他们也知道这一点，但重点不是这个。对，正确的回答不是“我会使用从互联网上找来的二叉树代码”，那样是行不通的。所以，你想讨论最好和最糟的时刻吗？好吧，最美好的时刻我不知道自己有没有，除了从来没有彻底搞砸别人的问题之外……但是我的最糟时刻——那最糟糕的面试官经历呢？你有没有过面试别人的时候，觉得非常深刻之类的事情？好吧，没有，但我确实有一个最糟糕的经历。我当时在一场面试中，那天要面好几轮，我想大概有四五场，那是第一场或第二场。这个人问了我一个非常开放式的问题，类似于这种估算类型的问题。
And I was like really going very in depth on it, like kind of, you know, exploring all the possibilities and waiting for them to guide me into like, okay, yeah, that's good enough. Or like, okay, let's get to a final answer. You know, know like kind of seeing like where how much detail they wanted me to get into um and then uh kind of by the end of it they said you know i i don't really think you have any technical ability whatsoever um oh and it was just like oh what like i was and you can't explain right like i was like can you even say
然后我非常深入地进行了解答，比如探索了所有的可能性，等待他们引导我得出诸如“好的，这足够好了”或者“好的，让我们得出最终答案”之类的结论。你知道的，就像是看看他们到底希望我深入到什么细节程度，然后到最后的时候，他们说：“你知道的，我觉得你根本没有任何技术能力。”哦，那种感觉就像是“啊？什么？”而且你无法辩解，就像是：“你甚至能这么说吗？”
after that so then i was kind of like well you know i was just like waiting for you to tell me like when you wanted me to start you know coding or when you were thought i had given enough detail and like no i think you're just trying to dodge having to do any coding i was just like oh oh my gosh okay oh that's gut-wrenching so it was at the beginning or at the end of the day that was like the second interview out of like oh no so you still have to face the you know most majority of the day after that yeah but you gotta kind of like jason said shake it off because like just because that guy was that way doesn't mean other people will be um and if i go through with a bad attitude like it's just gonna everybody else is just gonna
在这之后，我当时就有点像：“好吧，我刚才只是在等你们告诉我什么时候让我开始写代码，或者什么时候你们觉得我提供的细节已经够了。”而他们却说：“不，我觉得你只是在逃避写代码。”我当时就想：“哦，天哪，好吧。”哦，那真是让人揪心。那是面试刚开始还是接近一天结束的时候？那是大约五场面试中的第二场。哦，不！所以在那之后你还得面对一整天的大部分时间。是的，但你必须像杰森说的那样把阴霾甩掉，因为那个家伙那样并不代表其他人也那样。如果我带着糟糕的态度继续下去，其他人只会
assume that i'm that's me normally yeah yeah definitely so i actually don't have a best moment either i think it's actually pretty hard to have a best moment interview right so i got offered i'll talk about my uh worst interview interviewee moments um so as an interviewee it's similar to patrick you know i did like a lot of you know computer science theory and so um i had this one um stage of an interview where somebody was asking just kind of very specific questions on um like this certain type of architecture that i just never been exposed to it's like i never took a class on like networking or or anything like that so these are kind of like very specific networking questions and uh it was just really it's just really hard because i i i kept like saying variety of things and there's sometimes when the person was trying to guide me in one direction but like
假设我平时就是那样的人。是的，完全同意。其实我也没有什么最美好的时刻。我觉得要在面试中有个最美好的时刻其实挺难的。所以我拿到过offer，说说我最糟糕的面试者经历吧。作为面试者，这和帕特里克很像，我做了很多计算机科学理论方面的研究，所以我有过这样一轮面试，有人问了一些非常具体的问题，关于某种我从未接触过的特定架构。就好像我从来没上过网络课或者类似的东西，所以这些都是非常具体的网络问题。这真的很艰难，因为我一直
by guiding me they were saying things that like opened up holes in the original problem so i was like oh well now there's this hole in this problem so i could just do it this way and they're like okay yeah but what if you couldn't do it that way and it's like i just knew that they wanted me to say something but i didn't know what it was what that they wanted me to say and i just felt so helpless but um but like patrick said you just have to shake that one off it actually went pretty bad the person about halfway through the interview started going on like opened up their computer and started like chatting like i don't know like it's hard to say if someone's taking notes or chatting i'm pretty
在说各种各样的话，有时对方试图引导我朝一个方向发展，但通过引导，他们说出了一些暴露出原先问题漏洞的话，所以我当时想：“哦，好吧，现在这个问题里有个漏洞，所以我可以这么做。”他们就会说：“好吧，但是如果你不能那样做呢？”这就好像我明明知道他们想让我说点什么，但我却不知道他们到底想让我说什么。我当时感到非常无助。但正如帕特里克所说，你只能把那次经历甩在脑后。那场面试实际上进行得相当糟糕，面试官在进行到大约一半时，开始打开电脑聊天。我不知道该怎么说，很难判断对方是在做笔记还是在聊天，但我非常
sure this person was just like chatting to other people did i get a joke interviewer talk to me joke interviewee are you guys testing me it was so bad but uh my worst interviewer moment i guess i have two one really short i was a phone interview and the person like pretty quickly into the interview it's not like i had been kind of like badgering this person but like you know like like relatively quickly in the interview, you just started crying. And I think it was just like the pressure was just too much that they were putting on themselves. That's just sad. It was just really super awkward. And then I'm only laughing because I'm remembering just how awkward it was.
确信这个人当时就是在跟其他人聊天。我是不是遇到过搞笑的面试官？开玩笑的，我是搞笑的面试者。你们是在测试我吗？太糟糕了。不过我最糟糕的面试官经历，我想我有两次。一次非常短，那是一场电话面试，面试官在面试开始后不久——并不是我一直在纠缠这个人，而是相对较快地——就开始哭了。我想这大概是他们给自己施加的压力太大了。那真是太令人难过了。场面超级尴尬。我笑只是因为我想起了当时有多么尴尬。
And the other one, it was an in-person interview and it's the same scenario the person was extremely nervous and um we were on a whiteboard and the person had these expo markers and they were furiously writing but they were left-handed and so as they were writing they were kind of smudging the whiteboard with their hand and then they were like profusely sweating because they were so nervous so they kept rubbing their hand and then they were like profusely sweating because they were so nervous so they kept rubbing their forehead and then that kit this the the expo marker like you know migrated to their forehead and they had just like they looked like they had like kind of like these like native american tribal tattoos like all over their face but it was all these
另一个面试是线下面试，情况也一样，那个人非常紧张，我们在白板前，他手里拿着Expo马克笔，拼命地写着，但他是个左撇子，所以写字的时候手会把白板蹭脏，而且因为太紧张，他满头大汗，所以不停地用手擦额头，然后那些Expo马克笔的墨水就蹭到了他额头上，看起来就像是脸上画了那种美洲原住民的部落图腾一样，全都是
different color expo markers and you didn't say anything i was like hey you know after the first problem i was like let's go get a get something to drink so we went and got a drink we came back it was like he got a soda and he was kind of like his hand was shaking so he's shaking the soda so no he uh like he turned around he didn't even have a chance to open the soda he turned around and the soda flew out of his sweaty hand and hit the wall and then exploded. And both of us and the whiteboard got like showered in like very foamy Coca-Cola. And it was disgusting. That's not funny.
各种颜色的Expo马克笔，而你什么都没说。我当时想，嘿，在第一个问题之后，我说我们去喝点东西吧，于是我们去买了一杯喝的，回来的时候，他拿了一罐苏打水，手有点抖，所以他在晃那个苏打水。接着，他转过身，甚至还没来得及打开苏打水，罐子就从他出汗的手里飞了出去，砸在墙上然后炸开了。我们俩和白板上都溅满了那种非常多泡沫的可口可乐。太恶心了。这可不好笑。
That's like just depressing. That was the worst interview that I've ever given in my life. And I actually, I probably gave a little too much detail and if you're listening or if you're friends yeah i apologize um and you know i still thought it was hilarious um no hard feelings but but that was just it was just so bad oh okay time for book of the show book of the show so my book is actually a series of comic books called locky and key and i thought it was very well done basically um the thing that i thought was really cool about it is you know without giving too much away um there's this house full of keys and each key it's almost kind of like the twilight zone where each key kind of like bends the world in a way
这简直让人沮丧。那是我这辈子经历过的最糟糕的面试。而且实际上，我可能透露了太多细节，如果你在听或者你是我的朋友，是的，我道歉。不过你知道，我还是觉得这挺搞笑的，没有恶意，但那场面试真的是太糟糕了。好吧，又到了本期推荐书单的时间了。我的书其实是一系列名为《洛克与钥匙》（Locke & Key）的漫画书，我觉得它做得非常棒。基本上，我觉得它很酷的一点是，在不剧透太多的情况下，有一栋充满了钥匙的房子，每一把钥匙都差不多像是《阴阳魔界》里的情节，每把钥匙都能以某种方式扭曲世界
that's not you know generally bent you know and it just each key causes something crazy some kind of crazy power or whatnot um the book is a little too like generic you know like like they gave themselves too much freedom it's sort of like you have any key and then uh without spoiling too much the the the antagonist ends up being just also kind of generic but the the creativity is absolutely astounding and the kind of crazy combinations of keys and all the things they do with them i thought it was a really awesome series and i highly recommend it nice so it's a like comic book or a yeah it's like 20 or 30 issues okay but you know i don't really like you know like spider-man superman any of that but i do uh really like kind of reading comics
这种扭曲通常是意想不到的，而且每一把钥匙都会带来一些疯狂的效果或者类似超能力的东西。这本书有点太大众化了，就好像他们给自己的自由度太高了。有点像是你拥有任何钥匙，然后，在不剧透太多的情况下，反派最后也变得有点大众化。不过它的创意绝对是惊人的，各种疯狂的钥匙组合以及他们用这些钥匙做的事情，我觉得这是一个非常棒的系列，我强烈推荐它。不错，所以它是一本漫画书，或者是，对的，大概有20到30期。好吧，不过你知道，我其实不太喜欢蜘蛛侠、超人之类的，但我确实挺喜欢看漫画的
it's kind of light. And, you know, usually I really like the artwork and everything. But, you know, this is like more like kind of not serious comic, but it's not one of these like superhero kind of like crazy fantasy comics. It's meant to be. It's, I guess, a horror comic. Oh, okay. So I chose this book before i knew what you were picking but it also has lock in it um with l-o-c-k-e but this is the lies of lock lamora um and this is a fictional book by scott lynch that i just finished well
感觉很轻松。而且通常我真的很喜欢它的艺术风格之类的。但是，这更像是一种不那么严肃的漫画，但它又不是那种超级英雄式的疯狂奇幻漫画。它应该是一本，我猜是一本恐怖漫画。哦，好吧。所以我在知道你选什么书之前就选了这本书，但它也包含lock这个词，拼写是l-o-c-k-e，不过这是斯科特·林奇（Scott Lynch）刚刚写完的一本小说《利器与谎言》（The Lies of Locke Lamora），好吧
actually listening to but i'll call it reading um and it is pretty good so it's a like crime thriller kind of like oh think like oceans 13 like a heist and um but it's set in like a fantasy world so it's this kind of really interesting world where they don't get into as much as it as like most science fiction would um, the details of how this world came to be and kind of the rules of the world. But the author does a good job of setting up an interesting environment for this thing to take place in. And I believe it's going to turn into a trilogy.
实际上我是在听有声书，但我姑且称之为阅读吧。它真的很不错。所以它是一部犯罪惊悚小说，有点像《十一罗汉》那种大盗题材，但它的背景设定在一个奇幻世界里。所以这是一个非常有趣的奇幻世界，作者并没有像大多数科幻小说那样，深入探讨这个世界的起源以及世界的各种规则。但是作者很好地为这个故事搭建了一个有趣的背景环境。而且我相信它会发展成一个三部曲。
I think the second book is already out and maybe the third is in the works as well. I'll have to look into it. Oh, so it's pretty new then. Yeah, but it's probably like three or four years old. I'd have to look into it but it oh so it's pretty new then but it yeah but i it's probably like three or four years old i'd have to look i don't really know um but i just read it and i really enjoyed it and it's not like some trilogies end where like it's just the trilogy is just really one long book um but this seems to have you know it like you could just read
我想第二本书已经出版了，第三本可能也在筹备中。我得去查查看。哦，所以它挺新的。对，不过可能已经出版三四年了。我得去查一下，哦，所以它挺新，但对，它大概有三四年历史了，我得去查查看，我其实不太清楚。但我刚刚读完，真的很喜欢。它不像某些三部曲那样，整个三部曲读起来就像是一本极长的小说，而这本书似乎给人的感觉是，你可以只读
one book and be happy gotcha cool cool yeah i'll check this out so wait what's the theme again is it like futuristic or no so it's it's like a fantasy world so it's not really futuristic um and there's like a little bit of magic um i don't really know it's not like medieval how would i call it i don't even know like the age maybe like a little like steampunk oh okay but not like with like balloon steam boats or anything okay cool yeah maybe like 18th century maybe like 18th century but like in a fantasy world now i'm trying to remember if there was any technology in the book that would have placed it in a specific time. I love seeing some of these futuristic
一本书也能觉得很满足。原来如此，酷，酷。我会去看看的。等等，主题是什么来着？是科幻未来风格的吗？不是，它是一个奇幻世界，所以不算真正意义上的未来风格，里面还有一点魔法。我也不太清楚，它不完全是中世纪的，该怎么形容呢？我甚至不知道算什么时代，也许有点像蒸汽朋克？哦，好吧，但不是那种有热气球飞艇之类的。好吧，酷，也许像18世纪吧，也许像18世纪的奇幻世界。现在我在努力回想书里是否有任何能将它定位在特定时期的科技。我喜欢看一些这种未来风格
but the art styles from the past. There was this artist that did pin-up art. These are kind of like 1920s, 1930s. Very pastel, very flat colors. But then the cars would be flying cars
但艺术风格却来自过去的设定。曾有一位艺术家创作过画报女郎风格的艺术作品。这些有点像20世纪20年代、30年代的风格。色彩非常柔和，非常扁平。但车子却是会飞的汽车
or like the technology would be like something outlandish right and uh i always thought those contrasts was pretty cool nice nice all right so time for tool of the show tool of the show my tool this show is du lingo so long story short i uh used to be pretty much fluent in italian i lived there for a while lived in italy for a while um but uh i've since lost almost all of my fluency uh literally all my fluency and so i wanted to build it back and you know i have i have brady and I want to sort of teach him Italian and all of that. So I picked up this app. It's really cool.
或者科技产品是一些离奇古怪的东西，对吧？我一直觉得这种对比非常酷。很棒，很棒。好的，那么接下来是本期推荐工具时间。我这次推荐的工具是多邻国（Duolingo）。简单来说，我以前基本上能说流利的意大利语，我在那儿住过一段时间，在意大利住过一段时间。但是，从那以后我几乎失去了所有的流利度，字面意义上失去了所有的流利度，所以我想重新捡起来。而且，你知道，我有布雷迪（Brady），我想教他意大利语之类的。所以我下载了这个应用。它真的很酷。
It sort of gamifies learning a language. And I feel like it does a really good job. I mean, my opinions, I feel like I can't really give it a fair, you know, assessment because I already know Italian. So I'm kind of, you know, bree i already know italian so so i'm kind of you know breezing through it but i but i really feel like uh if you had no idea um about the language maybe i'll try chinese or something next maybe i'll try learning italian and i'll tell you it it walks you through it at like such a fundamental level that uh that that you could that you could uh you could pick up any language with it so you can get back your flu. I'll try this out and try to become fluent and try to learn Italian and become fluent,
它把学习语言游戏化了。我觉得它做得很好。我的意思是，我个人的看法可能不太公平，因为我已经懂意大利语了，所以我有点在，我本来就懂意大利语，所以我学起来可以说是轻车熟路。但我真的觉得，如果你对这门语言一无所知，也许我下次可以试试中文什么的，也许我该尝试学学意大利语，我告诉你，它会从非常基础的层面引导你，让你能通过它掌握任何语言，这样你就能找回流利度了。我会试试这个，争取变得流利，尝试学习意大利语并达到流利水平，
and then you can tell me how good I did. All right, sounds good. One thing that's particularly cool about it is, although I found out later, like only through using the app, that it's not that accurate. It gives you a lot of leverage. But it has this thing where you speak in the language to the microphone, and it evaluates your accent.
然后你就可以告诉我我学得有多好了。好的，听起来不错。它特别酷的一点是，虽然我后来才发现，通过使用这个应用才发现，其实它并没有那么准确。它给了你很大的宽容度。但它有一个功能是，你对着麦克风说这门语言，然后它会评估你的口音。
I thought that was pretty cool. But then you told me it wasn't accurate, so now I don't think it's cool. Yeah, that's the thing. I don't know. Either I have a really good fake Italian accent, or it's just giving me way too much credit. Play some of the Mario soundtrack or something something like Mario speaking and Super Mario Brothers or whatever one of the games he actually talks in and see what it gives him yeah it's a me Mario 100 percent all right, so my tool is by a company called Autodesk and it's one, two, three D design. And, um, so if you've heard before, I think we even talked about SketchUp, which Jason was talking about CAD tools before and talking about using Blender and SketchUp was something that a company had made and then i think they sold it to someone else now but um was like a free you know kind of more
我觉得这挺酷的。但后来你告诉我它不准确，所以现在我觉得它一点也不酷了。对，就是这样。我不知道。要么是我有一口非常逼真的意大利语假口音，要么就是它给我的评分太高了。放点《马里奥》的配乐或者别的什么，比如马里奥说话的声音，超级马里奥兄弟或者其他他真正开口说话的游戏，看看它会给出什么评价。太棒了，是我就爱马里奥，100%命中。好了，我的工具是一家名为Autodesk的公司开发的，叫做123D Design。然后，如果你以前听说过，我想我们甚至讨论过SketchUp，杰森之前谈到过CAD工具，提到了Blender和SketchUp，这是另一家公司制作的，后来我想他们把它卖给别人了，但它是一款免费的、更
basic cad tool and so this one two three d design is in the same vein and um i picked it up because i've been trying to learn some 3d modeling and there's like you know all these recommendations and depending on what you want to do or what it's targeted to it's like blender is you know good for like you know artistic stuff and you can use it for kind of precision mechanical drawings but you know maybe it's not the best i don't really know um but this one seems good it's a free it's not open source though um and it's called one two three d design um so if you're interested in learning cad and looking for something that seems simple yet still like you still quite powerful, then you should check it out.
基础的CAD工具。所以这个123D Design也是一脉相承的。我下载它是为了尝试学习一些3D建模，网上有各种各样的推荐，取决于你想做什么或者它的目标受众是什么，比如Blender适合做艺术方面的东西，你也可以用它来做精密的机械绘图，但可能它并不是最好的，我其实不太确定。不过这个看起来不错，它是免费的，但不是开源的，名字叫123D Design。所以如果你对学习CAD感兴趣，并且在寻找一款看起来简单却依然功能强大的工具，那么你应该去看看。
So if I remember correctly, Autodesk made 3D Studio Max, and then I believe they also bought Maya. Is that correct? Yeah, so they actually, this company is like, yeah, they have like a whole host of, yeah, like all the major types of CAD software they do i'm trying to click through to see all their apps now but um yeah i'm amazed that like this company has so much experience and like so much invested in in paid um apps which would make a free one but i'm assuming like the other ones
如果我没记错的话，Autodesk开发了3D Studio Max，然后我想他们还收购了玛雅（Maya）。对吗？是的，所以实际上这家公司，对，他们拥有全套的各种主流CAD软件。我正试图点进去看看他们所有的应用，但是，是的，我很惊讶这家公司有如此丰富经验，并且在付费应用上投入了这么多，却还推出了一款免费应用。不过我猜像其他那些
maybe this is like the gateway to getting people to buy these more professional ones. Yeah, so they make 3D Studio Max, Maya, this more professional one called Inventor, I guess, AutoCAD. Oh, they make AutoCAD too, wow. Yeah, so they make a lot of these kinds of products. And this one seems like it doesn't have a lot of crazy features, like a lot of the macros and things for doing like bill of material and tolerances and stuff i haven't seen in it which i know some of the other ones do um but it seems like it is in a similar vein to the more complicated products so like if you got to the point where you outgrew this one you could transfer your knowledge into one of their paid
也许这就像是一个引导人们购买那些更专业软件的入口。对，他们制作了3D Studio Max、Maya，还有一款更专业的叫Inventor的软件，我猜还有AutoCAD。哦，他们也做AutoCAD，哇。对，所以他们制作了很多这类产品。这款产品看起来没有太多花哨的功能，比如我没有在里面看到很多用于生成物料清单、公差等功能的宏和工具，我知道其他一些软件有这些功能，但它似乎与那些更复杂的产品一脉相承。所以，如果你用熟了这款软件，超越了它的上限，你就可以把这些知识转移到他们的付费
products um yeah which i guess is the point but also an advantage because then you don't have to relearn something because uh you know like blender you couldn't do exactly what you needed in blender and you know you have to relearn another tool um which i'm not picking on blender i don't really know that may not be an issue with blender um yeah i mean i've used blender quite a bit but uh you know i uh i mainly used it for artistic things so yeah i don't know how precise it is per se yeah cool so on to well you're calling it unix shells and i called it unix commands but it's just general unix knowledge yeah unix unix knowledge so one thing i have to warn everybody by listening this podcast um you warn everybody by listening to this podcast, after you listen to this podcast, look in the mirror,
产品中去。是的，我猜这既是他们的目的，也是一个优势，因为这样你就不需要重新学习新东西了。因为，你知道，就像Blender，如果你无法在Blender中实现你想要的确切效果，你就必须重新学习另一个工具。我不是在针对Blender，我其实对它不太了解，这可能对Blender来说根本不是问题。是的，我的意思是，我用过挺多次Blender的，但是，你知道，我主要用它来做艺术创作，所以，是的，我不知道它到底有多精确。好的，那么接下来，你把它叫作Unix Shell，我叫它Unix命令，但它其实就是通用的Unix知识。对，Unix知识。所以，有一件事我必须提醒所有听这个播客的人，
and you might have a huge neck beard and not even know it. What? I don't know if my wife's going to approve of that. No, my wife definitely wouldn't approve. But, yeah, it's, you know, if you need to know something about a very specific way a eunuch man behaves, look for your closest neckbeard. We also just lost all our female listeners.
听了这期播客之后，去照照镜子，
That man or woman will definitely help you with their eunuch's fantastic knowledge. We'll cover some of the common shells. I've used a bunch of these but to be honest uh only one of them i've really liked so uh maybe you had a different experience but uh okay yeah so there's born shell seashell corn shell thompson shell there's also tc shell which is a derivative of seashell and i've've used all of them, and in my opinion, they all were terrible. The only good shell, and fortunately, a lot of people agree with Patrick and I here, so it's the default on almost any Unix computer nowadays, is Bash.
你会发现自己长出了浓密的程序员大胡子却浑然不知。什么？我不知道我老婆会不会同意这个。不，我老婆绝对不会同意。但是，是的，如果你需要了解一个极客的某种特定行为方式，去找离你最近的大胡子程序员吧。我们刚刚还失去了所有的女性听众。
Bash Shell. Actually, I've been wanting to try out, do you know anything about fish shell? I've never heard of fish shell. People on, like, Hacker News are always talking about this fish shell. Is it F-I-S-H? Yeah, I keep telling myself I need to check it out. But all right, I'll keep looking. Keep going. So I'm looking at Bash shell.
那个男人或女人绝对会用他们丰富的极客知识来帮助你。我们将介绍一些常见的Shell。我用过其中很多个，但老实说，其中我真正喜欢的只有一个，所以也许你们有不同的经历，但好吧，是的，这里有Bourne Shell、C Shell、Korn Shell、Thompson Shell，还有作为C Shell衍生版本的TCSH Shell，我都用过，依我看，它们全都很糟糕。唯一好的Shell，幸运的是，很多人都同意帕特里克和我的看法，它几乎是当今任何Unix计算机上的默认设置，那就是Bash。
Bash shell was a replacement for Born shell. But I can't find out if bash is supposed to be an acronym or what regardless so we broke so basically there's a number of sort of core commands that will really make your life much more productive as a someone who's like a programmer has to mess with a lot of you know structured data now by structured data i mean like sql or something like that i'm talking about you know like comma separated files space separated files if you want to write something to like a flat file structure and you want to do something kind of quick and dirty
Bash Shell。其实我一直想尝试一下，你了解Fish Shell吗？我从来没听过Fish Shell。黑客新闻（Hacker News）之类网站上的人总是在谈论这个Fish Shell。是F-I-H吗？不，是F-I-S-H。对，我一直告诉自己我得去看看。不过好吧，我继续找，你接着说。所以我正在看Bash Shell。
the best thing is to just kind of write ascii text to a file and then do some manipulation and so the unix shell is actually extremely good at this it has a lot of functionality people don't know about so we'll start with some of the easy ones so there's cat cat lets you basically it takes the contents of a file and it writes it to standard out. Actually, we should probably explain what these are. So any Unix shell has streams. So it has standard in, which is a stream of data flowing into a program. Now, by default, that stream comes from the keyboard.
Bash Shell是Bourne Shell的替代品。但我查不到Bash到底算是一个首字母缩略词还是别的什么。不管怎样，所以我们，基本上有许多核心命令能极大地提高你的工作效率，特别是作为一个程序员，需要处理大量结构化数据的时候。现在我说的结构化数据不是指SQL之类的内容，我指的是逗号分隔文件、空格分隔文件。如果你想把数据写入某种平面文件结构，并且想做一些快速且粗暴的处理，
So you can run a program. It can say, what is your name? You know, you type in, you know, you could write a program like this. You type in your name, hit enter. Now, when you hit enter, the information flows through standard in to the program, which is kind of waiting for it. And then it says, hey, hello, Jason, or hello, Patrick, right? So standard in now you can also if you don't want to have to use the keyboard you can cat a file which will
最好的办法就是把ASCII文本写入文件，然后进行一些处理。所以Unix Shell实际上非常擅长这一点，它有很多人们不知道的功能。我们从一些简单的开始，比如cat。cat基本上能让你读取文件的内容并将其写入标准输出。其实，我们可能应该解释一下这些是什么。任何Unix Shell都有流（Stream）。它有标准输入（standard in），这是流入程序的数据流。默认情况下，这个流来自键盘。
take a file and sort of dump it to the screen but then you can use the pipe character and you can take things that would have been dumped to the screen and sort of pipe them or redirect them into another program. So instead of typing JSON, you could have a file that has JSON in it, cat that file, pipe it to your program, and now your program runs with JSON. So if you wanted a program that executed some process on some data, but you didn't want to have to put the file name in the program, and then you make a change, now you have to put the file name in the program, and then you make a change, now you have to rebuild the whole program, right?
所以你可以运行一个程序。它可能会问，你叫什么名字？你知道的，你输入，你知道的，你可以写这样一个程序。你输入你的名字，按回车键。现在，当你按回车键时，信息通过标准输入流向正在等待它的程序。然后它说，嘿，你好，杰森，或者你好，帕特里克，对吧？所以这就是标准输入。现在你也可以，如果你不想使用键盘，你可以cat一个文件，这会
The program could just read information as if it was coming from the keyboard, and then you use Unix streams to sort of feed whatever file you want through the program. So that's CAT, and that's sort of redirecting. There's also sed and awk. And now we're starting to get a little more complicated. Sed does a number of things, but the most common is find and replace. So again, you can have this stream of data that's coming through. Say you're catting a file, so you're just dumping a file,
这个程序可以像从键盘输入那样读取信息，然后你可以用Unix流把你想用的任何文件输入到程序中。所以这就是CAT，也就是某种重定向。还有sed和awk。现在我们要开始讲得稍微复杂一点了。Sed有很多功能，但最常见的是查找和替换。所以同样地，你可以让这种数据流通过。比方说你在cat一个文件，也就是在转储一个文件，
but you only want the words patrick from the file so any line or or another way of saying is anytime you see the word patrick you want to replace it with jason because of course you know let's be honest who would hey hey hey jason so so you would use said and then you do I think it's like, s slash Patrick slash Jason slash g. So there's a little bit, again, it's Unix, so it's going to have this crazy wizardry, and you'll have to look it up on the internet. Don't worry, all of us have to.
但你只想获取文件中的patrick这个词，所以任何行，或者说换句话说，任何你看到patrick这个词的地方，你都想把它换成jason，因为当然了，说实话，谁会……嘿嘿嘿，jason。所以你会用sed，然后我记得命令大概是，s斜杠Patrick斜杠Jason斜杠g。所以这里有点，没错，这是Unix，所以它会有这种疯狂的魔法，你得去网上查一下。别担心，我们所有人都得查。
Except for the guy with the neckbeard, he has it memorized. But you'd use sed to sort of do things, like simple things like that. awk lets you do even more complex things. But together, they both sort of have a nice union. Like between the two of them, you can do a lot of cool text manipulation. So then you have diff and patch. And so this will take diff will say like if I have two files, so like I made a copy of a file and then a piece
除了那个留着大胡子的家伙，他已经背下来了。但你会用sed来做一些事情，比如像这样简单的操作。awk能让你做更复杂的事情。但它们结合在一起，可以说是强强联合。就像在它们两个的配合下，你可以做很多很酷的文本处理。然后就是diff和patch。这可以用来，diff会说，如果我有两个文件，比如我复制了一个文件，然后有一段
of code and then i made changes to it diff will tell me what lines have changed between the two files and patch lets me instead of having to send someone a whole new file just send them the delta that they can then patch into their file and reflect my new version of the file so it captures the differences between two files versus diff is more for examining by eye and the same thing so you can you can also you can diff entire directories and it'll diff like everything inside the directories and you can also redirect diff to a file so now you have this diff file. You can send that to somebody and then he can patch your diff file
代码，然后我对它进行了修改，diff会告诉我两个文件之间哪些行发生了改变。patch能让我不用把一整个新文件发送给别人，而只需发送差异部分（delta），他们就可以把这个差异补丁打到他们的文件中，从而反映出我的新版本文件。所以它捕捉的是两个文件的差异，而diff更多是用来肉眼检查的。同样地，你也可以diff整个目录，它会对比目录里的所有内容，你还可以把diff的结果重定向到一个文件，这样你就有了一个diff文件。你可以把它发给别人，然后他就可以应用你的diff文件
and now he has the same changes you have for a bunch of directories. Yeah, so then there's TAR. Actually, do you know what TAR stands for? I have no idea. I'll look it up. Keep going. Terminal Archive or something. Okay, so what's the difference between
现在他也有了一堆目录的相同更改。好的，接下来是TAR。实际上，你知道TAR代表什么吗？我完全不知道。我查一下。你继续。终端归档（Terminal Archive）什么的？好吧，那么有什么区别呢？
tar and gzip? Yeah, so gzip takes a single file and then shrinks the file by using some compression, right? Tar will take a group of
tar和gzip？对，gzip处理单个文件，然后通过一些压缩来缩小文件大小，对吧？Tar会把一组
files and it basically just concatenates them together but it also stores a little bit of metadata so it knows where one file ended and the other began so tar stands for tape archive oh tape archive ah i guess now it makes more sense as terminal archive but it originated as tape it's interesting So you can actually use both of these together, right? So you can use tar on a directory to collapse the whole directory into one huge file and then use gzip on that file to make the file a reasonable size.
文件基本上串联在一起，但它也存储了一点元数据，这样它就知道一个文件在哪里结束，另一个从哪里开始。所以tar代表磁带归档（tape archive）。哦，磁带归档，呃，我猜现在把它理解成终端归档好像更说得通，但它最早起源于磁带，这挺有意思的。所以你实际上可以把这两个结合起来使用，对吧？你可以对一个目录使用tar，把整个目录压缩成一个巨大的文件，然后对该文件使用gzip，使文件大小变得合理。
And that's why if you're downloading, especially things for Unix, you download these files that have the extension.tar.gzip. And that's because that's exactly what they've done, right? They had a directory, they tarred it, and they gzipped it, and then they put it on the Internet. So what's crontab? So this is for when you want to run a script or program on a regular schedule. So something every hour or something every so often.
这就是为什么如果你在下载东西，尤其是Unix相关的软件，你会下载这些扩展名为.tar.gzip的文件。这是因为他们就是这么做的，对吧？他们有一个目录，将其打包成tar，然后用gzip压缩，接着放到互联网上。那么什么是crontab呢？这是当你想要按常规时间表运行脚本或程序时使用的。比如每隔一小时或者每隔一段时间运行一次的东西。
Yep, that's pretty much crontab. Yep, okay. Yeah, so like a bunch of programs on your computer that check, you know, the, that like, uh, check for updates and all that stuff. They all just, they're basically crontabs and you can actually, I think you can type crontab, maybe it's crontab dash H or something. One thing, oh, one thing we should mention for all of these commands, if you type man, which is short for manual, man space, and then the command, they give you like a whole dossier on how the command works and everything.
没错，基本上就是crontab。没错，好的。对，就像你电脑上的一堆程序，用来检查，你知道的，检查更新什么的。它们基本上都是crontab。实际上，我想你可以输入crontab，也许是crontab杠H什么的。有一点，哦，我们应该提到，对于所有这些命令，如果你输入man（是manual的缩写），man空格，然后是命令，它们会给你提供一整份关于该命令如何工作的详细资料。
So half of the things we'll say are wrong because we just look it up every time. But yeah, if you type crontab by itself, I would think, or maybe the dash L, it gives you a list of all the programs that you have scheduled. So next is BG Jobs and Kill.
所以我们说的话有一半是错的，因为我们每次都是现场查的。不过对，如果你单独输入crontab，我想，或者加上杠L，它会给你列出你安排的所有程序。接下来是后台任务（BG Jobs）和终止（Kill）。
These kind of all work together. So BG says... An Assassin's Toolkit? What's that? An Assassin's Toolkit. I was guessing what they're for. BG is for Back... Background. Yeah.
这些基本上都是配合使用的。所以BG说……杀手工具包？那是什么？杀手工具包。我刚才在猜它们是干什么用的。BG是用来……后台（Background）。对。
Basically, it takes your program runs in the background so you can keep doing other things on the terminal and your program will just you know run in the in the background until it's finished um jobs gives you a list of all the times that you've done this um so all the BG commands that haven't finished yet. And kill lets you kill one of those. So if you have one that's kind of going out of control, you just type kill and first type jobs, find out which number it is, and then type kill percent the number
基本上，它会让你的程序在后台运行，这样你就可以继续在终端上做其他事情，而你的程序就会在后台一直运行，直到完成。嗯，jobs会给你列出你这样做过的所有任务，嗯，所有还没完成的BG命令。而kill允许你终止其中一个。所以如果你有一个程序有点失控了，你只需输入kill，先输入jobs，查出它是哪个编号，然后输入kill百分号加编号
and it will kill that job. So I never get the PS right but PS lists the processes is that right? so you can get processes I have no idea, I've never used the history command is that the same thing as pushing up in bash shell? or control R and searching through your history?
它就会终止那个任务。我老是记不对ps，但ps是列出进程的，对吗？所以你可以获取进程。我完全不知道，我从来没用过history命令。这和在bash shell里按方向键上是一样的吗？或者用Ctrl+R在历史记录里搜索？
history just gives you a list of all the commands you've typed since you opened the shell. I've always just output my, it's like.bash history in my home directory. Oh, yeah. So this is a one-word command that does exactly that. That's useful.
history只会给你列出自你打开shell以来输入的所有命令。我通常只输出我的，就像家目录下的.bash_history文件。哦，对。所以这是一个能完全做到这一点的单字命令。这很有用。
See, this is why I do this podcast, so you can tell me things I didn't know. Yeah, so that's history so read link is a rare but extremely useful command you type read link and then dash f and then the name of a file and it gives you the full path to the file now if you do read link and then the file it gives you like the full path based on where you are now. But where you are now can be a symbolic link to some other directory, right? So we won't get into symbolic folders.
看，这就是我为什么要录这个播客的原因，这样你就能告诉我我不知道的事情。好，这就是history。所以readlink是一个很少见但极其有用的命令。你输入readlink，然后是杠f，接着是文件名，它就会给出文件的完整路径。现在，如果你输入readlink然后跟文件名，它会根据你当前的位置给你一个完整路径。但你当前的位置可能是指向其他目录的符号链接，对吧？所以我们就不深入探讨符号文件夹了。
It's kind of complicated. But you know, you do read link dash F and then some file and remember all these commands work in Mac as well as Unix. So if you have a Mac desktop or laptop, if you have a Mac Pro, if you roll that way, all these commands will work. So readlink-f the file, and it tells you exactly on the disk where that file is.
这有点复杂。不过你知道的，你输入readlink杠f加上某个文件，记住所有这些命令在Mac和Unix上都能用。所以如果你有一台Mac台式机或笔记本，如果你有一台Mac Pro，如果你喜欢用那个，所有这些命令都能用。所以输入readlink杠f加文件，它就会告诉你该文件在磁盘上的确切位置。
So that always kind of comes in handy. So actually, we talked about programming questions before and sometimes it's really easy to solve programming questions using a sort and unique um sort will just sort the lines in a file and unique will give you the unique occurrences it and also can give you counts so if you have like unique and then it occurred this many times or just the number of distinct lines in a file and so this can be useful for instance if you have like a log of all the ips that have visited your website you could unique them and then get just the number of unique ips and know how many unique visitors you had in the log file right so this like could be a common programming question you could solve this way although they might want you to actually do it programmatically there is a file
所以这总是派得上用场。实际上，我们之前讨论过编程问题，有时用sort和uniq可以非常轻松地解决编程问题。sort只是对文件中的行进行排序，uniq会给你不重复出现的行，它还可以给出计数。所以如果你有uniq，然后它出现了多少次，或者仅仅是文件中不同行的数量。这在某些情况下很有用，例如，如果你有一个访问过你网站的所有IP的日志，你可以用uniq处理它们，然后只获取唯一IP的数量，从而知道你的日志文件里有多少个独立访客，对吧？所以这可能是一个常见的编程问题，你可以用这种方式解决，尽管他们可能希望你实际用代码来实现，但确实有一个文件
or a unix command you could use to just do it yeah i think if you walked into an interview and like somebody said you know as patrick said like you know give me a histogram of you know the frequencies of ip addresses and instead of like instead of busting out C++, you just whipped out a one-liner in Bash and did the whole thing. I think that'd be pretty cool. You get some props for that. Like Patrick said,
或者一个你可以用来直接搞定的Unix命令。对，我想如果你走进一场面试，然后有人说，正如帕特里克（patrick）所说的那样，（你知道的）给我一个IP地址频率的直方图，而不是掏出C++，你只是在Bash里随手写了一行命令就把整件事搞定了。我觉得那会非常酷。你会因此赢得赞赏。就像帕特里克说的，
you probably still have to do the problem again. But that'd be pretty interesting. So the next ones are TR and TS. Actually, that's a typo in my notes. I meant TR and TR-S. Oh. So basically, TR... Let me make sure I get this right.
你可能还是得重新做这道题。但这会非常有趣。所以接下来的命令是TR和TS。实际上，我的笔记里有个拼写错误。我指的是TR和TR-S。哦。基本上，TR……让我确认一下我没记错。
I'm totally flubbing this. TR-S is a... Basically, okay. So TR dash s is a collapse command so for example let's say you have a file but this file is like maybe user generated content and what you really want is to you know split the file based on spaces spaces so that you can do a cut, which actually I'll cover cut as well. The list is getting longer. Yeah, that's right. So, you know, but some of the columns have, like, so you'll notice as if, like, you look at, say, the output of PS, right?
我完全搞砸了。TR杠s是一个……基本上，好吧。所以TR杠s是一个压缩命令。举个例子，假设你有一个文件，但这个文件可能是用户生成的内容，而你真正想要的是（你知道的）根据空格分割文件，以便你可以进行cut操作，实际上我也会讲到cut。列表越来越长了。对，没错。所以，你知道的，但有些列有，比如你会注意到，如果你查看ps的输出，对吧？
The output of PS has usually three columns, but then they use spaces so that all the columns kind of line up which is great for looking at it but if you want to write a program to analyze the output of ps it'd be much better if there was just one space between the three columns right then you wouldn't have to like write some code in c or C++ to like, you know, move that many spaces and all of that. So tr-s does exactly that. It looks for consecutive characters and then it collapses them. So like if you put in tr-s and then the letter e, you know, if you, if somebody put the word c and it would turn into sen, it would just like collapse all the consecutive e's together. This is really useful because the next command is cut. And cut lets you pull individual columns out of a, you
PS 的输出通常有三列，但它们使用空格使所有列对齐，这对于查看非常棒，但如果你想编写一个程序来分析 ps 的输出，如果三列之间只有一个空格会好得多，这样你就不用在 C 或 C++ 中写一些代码来移动那么多空格之类的了。所以 tr-s 正是做到这一点。它寻找连续的字符然后将它们合并。所以如果你输入 tr-s 然后输入字母 e，你知道，如果有人输入了单词 c，它就会变成 sen，它只会把所有连续的 e 合并在一起。这非常有用，因为下一个命令是 cut。而 cut 允许你从...
know, a Unix stream. So again, going back to the PS example, if I did a tr dash s, so now I only have, you know, one space separating all the columns now i can do a cut and then the space you can actually represent a space with like a you know a single quote space single quote then what that will do is it will cut the stream and then after that you do a dash f and then the number so if i did if I did cut space dash F one, it's going to pull the first column from that stream of information. So if I wanted say to kill every process that I started, I could do a PS and then I could do a,
你知道，一个 Unix 流中提取单独的列。所以再次回到 PS 的例子，如果我执行了 tr -s，现在我只有，你知道，一个空格分隔所有的列，现在我可以执行 cut，然后空格，你实际上可以用一个，你知道，单引号空格单引号来表示一个空格，然后它会做的是它会切割流，在那之后你执行 -f 然后是一个数字，所以如果我执行，如果我执行 cut 空格 -f 1，它将从该信息流中提取第一列。所以如果我想，比方说，杀死我启动的每一个进程，我可以执行一个 PS，然后我可以执行一个，
you know, send that to cut. And then now I have just this list of process ids that i could then you know go through and kill nice and grep is like the de facto search tool so if you have like a file and you want to look for something in that file you can use grep and there's all sorts of parameters for it as far as like expressing what you're looking for and tweaking the output, like showing stuff before and after the line that contains what you're looking for and all that wonderful stuff.
你知道，将其发送给 cut。然后现在我只有这个进程 ID 列表，我就可以，你知道，遍历并杀死它们。而 grep 就像是事实上的搜索工具，所以如果你有一个文件并且想在那个文件中寻找东西，你可以使用 grep，并且它有各种各样的参数，比如表达你在找什么以及调整输出，比如显示包含你所找内容的那一行的前后内容以及所有这些精彩的功能。
So grep is a really powerful command for searching for things in a single file or in multiple files. Yep. Yeah, if you want to do a whole directory, just do dash R and put the name of a directory instead of a file and it'll look at all the files for
所以 grep 是一个非常强大的命令，用于在单个文件或多个文件中搜索内容。没错。是的，如果你想搜索整个目录，只需使用 -r 并输入目录名称而不是文件名，它就会查看所有的文件以查找...
whatever you want it to search for. So then there's last but not least, there's xargs and this is pretty cool. What this does is it takes some Unix stream, it looks for all the new lines and then it splits that up.
你想要搜索的任何内容。接下来是，最后但同样重要的是，xargs，这个非常酷。它的作用是获取一些 Unix 流，寻找所有的换行符，然后将其拆分。
So each line of the stream is kind of its own thing. And then it takes whatever program you put after the X args, and it executes that program on that string. So for example, let's say you did a grep dash h dash r on a directory, and you looked for Patrick. So dash h will tell grep, return all of the file names that have the word Patrick in them.
所以流的每一行都有点像是它自己的东西。然后它获取你在 xargs 之后放置的任何程序，并在该字符串上执行该程序。例如，假设你在一个目录上执行了 grep -h -r，并且你寻找 Patrick。所以 -h 会告诉 grep，返回所有包含单词 Patrick 的文件名。
Then you could pipe that to xargs and then say xargs emacs and it'll open emacs with all those files all ready to go so that you could change Patrick to JSON. So... so that you could change Patrick to Jason. So. This is exhilarating, my friend. Best podcast content ever.
然后你可以通过管道将它传给 xargs，然后说 xargs emacs，它会打开包含所有这些随时可用文件的 emacs，以便你可以将 Patrick 改为 JSON。所以……以便你可以将 Patrick 改为 Jason。所以。这真是令人兴奋，我的朋友。史上最棒的播客内容。
Oh, man. Just type this into your terminal and follow along with us. Yeah. So now we have, this will be a little more interesting, some rare but useful commands. We have a couple on here. Have you ever used this one?
噢，天哪。只要把这个输入到你的终端里，跟我们一起操作就行了。是的。所以现在我们有，这将更有趣一些，一些罕见但有用的命令。我们这里有几个。你用过这个吗？
Nope. None of the remainder that you're going to talk about I've even ever heard of before. Okay. We'll go through these pretty quick. Expand turns taps to spaces. so one thing everyone should know if if you leave the podcast with one bit of information know that the tab key is evil and should be abolished and anyone who thinks the tab character should exist is a is a bad bad bad person and so expand agrees with me expand takes any tabs and uh deletes the tab and replaces it with spaces so you can open a file i can open a
没有。你将要谈论的其余部分我甚至都没听说过。好的。我们很快过一遍。Expand 把制表符转成空格。所以每个人都应该知道的一点是，如果从这个播客里带走一条信息，那就是制表符键是邪恶的，应该被废除，任何认为制表符应该存在的人都是一个彻头彻尾的坏人，所以 expand 同意我的观点，expand 会获取任何制表符，呃，删除制表符并用空格替换它，这样你可以打开一个文件，我可以打开一个
file and mine won't look totally screwed up because my tab width is different um fmt is short for format and you know sometimes you might have you know you might have a lot of data and like you might have some huge spreadsheet that you want to put into a terminal or something and it just like it's like the line is 4 000 characters long and it just looks ridiculous and it just like half of the words get or not half the words but you know some of the words get cut off at the edge of the page because they wrap around. So FMT, you just pipe your, you know,
文件，而我的看起来不会完全一团糟，因为我的制表符宽度不同。嗯，fmt 是 format（格式化）的简写，你知道，有时你可能会有很多数据，比如你可能有一些巨大的电子表格，你想把它放进终端或者其他地方，然后它就像是，那行有 4000 个字符长，看起来荒谬极了，而且它就像是有一半的单词被，或者不是一半的单词，但你知道，有些单词在页面边缘被截断了，因为它们换行了。所以 FMT，你只需将你的，你知道，
whatever you're streaming to FMT and it just comes out looking pretty. I like my output to be pretty. Yeah, pretty output is guaranteed path to success. Even better than a successful interview is having pretty output. So then there's quirky commands.
你正在流式传输的内容传给 FMT，它出来时就会很好看。我喜欢输出结果漂漂亮亮的。是的，漂亮的输出是通往成功的保证路线。甚至比成功的面试还要好，那就是拥有漂亮的输出。接下来是一些古怪的命令。
Have you ever used these, cal or banner? No, I've never heard of any of the ones I told you already. Are you on a Mac now? You surpassed my knowledge, yes. Type banner and then type some text okay i feel like this is even more compelling a more compelling podcast what i don't really know how to explain this so what is the point of this banner and then you put in some text and uh it just makes your text look ridiculous it just made it really really big
你用过这些吗，cal 或者 banner？不，我从来没听说过你刚才告诉我的任何一个。你现在用的是 Mac 吗？你超越了我的知识，是的。输入 banner 然后输入一些文本。好吧，我觉得这更引人入胜，这是一个更引人入胜的播客，我真的不知道该怎么解释这个，所以这个 banner 的意义何在，然后你输入一些文本，呃，它只是让你的文本看起来很荒谬，它只是把它变得非常非常大
and repeat it over and over like from way back in the day when people had like dot matrix printers or something and the banner is like somehow useful for that i don't know it's bizarre okay interesting so it just takes the letter so those of you who weren't watching my screen, if you type banner and then test, it makes like ASCII art of the word test, basically. Yeah. And like, it's just crazy that every Mac computer on earth has this completely useless program on it. Cal is also pretty useless.
并且一遍又一遍地重复，就像很久以前人们拥有点阵打印机之类的东西的时候一样，而 banner 对此不知为何是有用的，我不知道，这很诡异。好的，有趣。所以它只是获取字母，所以那些没有看我屏幕的人，如果你输入 banner 然后是 test，它基本上会把单词 test 做成 ASCII 艺术。是的。而且，地球上的每台 Mac 电脑上都有这个完全无用的程序，这太疯狂了。Cal 也相当无用。
It just gives you a calendar. Whoa, wait, that sounds good. I'm sure this was useful 40 years ago. No, I didn't know this. But now it's just a relic. I'm constantly going into my email program and using the calendar there. Oh, are you serious?
它只会给你一个日历。哇，等等，听起来不错。我确信这在 40 年前很有用。不，我不知道这个。但现在它只是一个遗物。我经常打开我的电子邮件程序并在那里使用日历。哦，你是认真的吗？
Yeah. It actually is useful? No, this seems good. Oh, and I can say how many months. Yeah, no, this is good i i'm i'm like only like 50 sure you're not playing alone no no no this seems good to me how do i make it up more than one month okay anyways i'll figure it out later this seems awesome well you know you'll be pretty pleased there's also a date command we didn't wait what that one but what does this do oh that's boring but between my calendar i have my command prompt already set up to show
是的。它实际上有用吗？不，这看起来不错。哦，我可以指定几个月。是的，不，这很好，我，我，我大概只有百分之五十的确定你不是在开玩笑。不，不，这对我来说看起来不错。我怎么把它弄成不止一个月呢？好吧，不管怎样，我待会儿会弄明白的，这看起来太棒了。好吧，你知道，你会相当高兴的，还有一个 date 命令，我们没有等那个，但是这个是做什么用的？哦，那太无聊了，不过在我的日历之间，我已经把我的命令提示符设置成显示
the date like this though okay all right well this was uh if this wasn't the best podcast ever hodgepodge of things it's been uh it pretty crazy year, definitely a crazy start of the year. And I think now that we've sort of got our feet in the water, we'll definitely dive into a programming language next episode. All right, sounds good. Now that you've won the lottery and you're a multimillionaire, you'll have more time to just sit on your uh couch and study programming languages yeah that's right well sipping mai tais in hawaii but but yeah your couch is not in hawaii nice yeah actually so uh um
像这样的日期。好吧，好吧，这真是个，如果这不是史上最棒的播客杂烩的话，这真是个，相当疯狂的一年，绝对是一个疯狂的开年。而且我认为现在我们已经算是在水里站稳脚跟了，我们绝对会在下一集深入探讨一门编程语言。好的，听起来不错。既然你中了彩票，成了一个千万富翁，你就有更多时间坐在你的，呃，沙发上研究编程语言了。是的，没错，一边在夏威夷啜饮迈泰酒，但是，但是是的，你的沙发不在夏威夷。太棒了。是的，实际上，呃，
i did not even come close to winning the lottery. Oh. But I do, if I did win the lottery, I would be able to print the amount I won in ridiculous ASCII art using the banner command. Yes. Yes. All right. Well, before we keep people up past their bedtimes listening to this long rambling podcast,
我甚至连中彩票的边都没沾到。哦。不过我确实，如果我中了彩票，我将能够用 banner 命令以荒谬的 ASCII 艺术打印出我赢得的金额。是的。是的。好吧，在我们让大家熬夜听这个冗长漫无边际的播客之前，
I think we'll call it to a close. Have a great start of the year. The start of the year has definitely been pretty exhilarating and exciting for Patrick and I. And I hope you guys are having an equally interesting and fun time. And keep checking out the books of the show. We really appreciate it that all those proceeds go to keeping the servers up and running
我想我们该结束了。祝大家新年开局大吉。对于我和帕特里克来说，今年开年绝对是非常令人兴奋和振奋的。我希望你们也过得同样有趣和愉快。请继续关注节目的书籍。我们非常感谢所有这些收益都用于维持服务器的正常运行，
you guys use terabytes of bandwidth and uh um the books are what help to support all that bandwidth so uh maybe maybe there isn't very many people actually out there listening to us maybe they're all just have like evil scripts running against us to download our podcast continuously in hopes that it will run out or cause us to go bankrupt. Well, you know, if we got DDoSed, because we have the unique visitors, if we got DDoSed by that many people, I would wear that as a badge of courage. Yes!
你们消耗了数 TB 的带宽，呃，呃，这些书正是支持所有这些带宽的动力，所以，呃，也许，也许实际上并没有多少人在听我们说话，也许他们所有人都在运行针对我们的恶意脚本，不断下载我们的播客，希望它能用尽或者导致我们破产。嗯，你知道，如果我们遭到 DDoS 攻击，因为我们有独特的访客，如果我们遭到那么多人的 DDoS 攻击，我会把它当成一枚勇敢的徽章。是的！
No, wait, no, no, no. That sounds like you're encouraging people to DDoS us. Please do not. Yeah. No, our server can't take it, really. I mean, they're mad enough as... they're mad enough at us as it is. So they don't need to get DDoSed.
不，等等，不，不，不。听起来你好像在鼓励人们对我们发起 DDoS 攻击。请不要这样。是的。不，我们的服务器承受不了，真的。我的意思是，他们对我们已经够生气的了……他们对我们已经够生气的了。所以他们不需要遭到 DDoS 攻击。
All right. Well, till next time. All right. Catch you guys later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的。那么，下次见。好的，回头见。片头曲是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须向我和帕特里克提供署名，并以相同方式分享。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来发表评论。